un lait dont je vais refaire le salut
qu'à sa l'ucav salut à tous salariés
thébaux pas bon ça va du coup la forme
ça va ça va je vais drive à paris battez
les retours je me suis ressourcé over
tranquille mais voilà quoi ça la petite
défaite à rennes notamment affecté non
beaucoup de sonorités bien dire sur le
match après ce jour compte prendre un
but à la dernière seconde n'a tellement
arracher deux matches comme ça depuis un
mois que vous qu'il peut pour une fois
perdre comme ça oui nous avons le droit
mais il ne faut pas que ça devienne une
habitude
nabhan on est apte à vue le superbe but
de leo messi
ouais l'atletico mais tous mes écrits
c'était très heureux non en fait je
regarde le match à fond le commentateur
anglais il dit oui très bien joué coq et
le défense du real messi n'a pas pu
repiquer au centre du match luis à la
83e minute
84e mme eva joly a repiqué au centre une
fois quoi à deux champions ont été
piqués mais en fait été très heureux de
la passe de suarez que le commentateur
c'est presque la passe de suarez que
messi failli te dis il faut être très
précis très difficile dans le bon tempo
va j'adore en fait le mec tu n'aimes pas
trop mais c'est en effet un repli qu'au
centre par chance bon là la passe était
très bien quant à même pas fait que soit
retiré bon ok tu les aimes dans un petit
soupirail comme ça mais nous il y avait
quand même la place c'était très simple
n'importe qui aurait fait oui même la
préfecture sans que je suis très en
forme ouais et c'est pas anodin
la donne ouais non mais je suis allé
avec jaillit qua non mais je me suis
nourri de manière très saine
forcément à midi
enfin voilà quoi j'ai fait face ou
d'asiatiques fait une petit souffle je
me suis et méprisés par par le mec qui
vont asiatique quoi j'ai joué une soupe
pho il m'a regardé feu feu feu le nom
s'équiper à chaud mais bon il ya quand
même le lac sans quoi il m'a dit feu et
on allait manger dans un resto coréen
avec la ddt ya trois jours n'avaient
fait le petit barbecue sur la petite
table devant moulins ouais il y avait le
truc comme on a fait à paris n'a eu
auparavant ramené à ray show avec du gaz
est très heureux une sous peu ça c'est
fort d'assurer sous pli et des raviolis
y avait du tofu de la viande c'est
n'importe quoi quand j'étais tellement
heureux
mais bon comme il y avait tellement de
trucs déjà dans la soupe en soit c'était
déjà n'importe quoi mais ils ont quand
même ramené du riz mais bon je veux bon
d'un point un peu pour c'est comme du
pain qui annonçait alors vlad du coup il
fait oui on va donner moins un peu de
soja ou les vieilles fermes à quoi ça
sert pas tu as des galas maintenant l'un
à elle te dit non alors hissés dans la
soupe aussi s'est fait dans ton assiette
tueur reste plus rien à [ __ ] justement
c'était très bon empêche mais tu aurais
été très très heureux en fait je me
donne bien moi toutes ces soupes osiatis
non plus non mais là je n'avais jamais
vu quoi ces restos cohérent coréen
recommandé par mon père et du coup
lorsque je vois ainsi que en fait il
faut répondre à tout le monde partout
comme un bébé tu ne sais plus à qui lui
répond la cei et je pourrai voir ça mais
aussi pendant le live
en fait on va regarder ensemble sûrement
mais tu peux aller sur le truc de twitch
un vêtement parce qu'en fait la plupart
des gens sont surtout issus attal ou
game watch bon voilà qui est la mieux
payée de sa grange on s'en fout tu vois
je suis déjà sur tweets je pense tout
bas je suis là bas les gens vont arriver
petit à petit et du coup la partie
d'hier est un peu vu ou juste fait vite
fait c'était au temps
qu'est ce que c'est non mais c'est bien
au stade à son nom c'est intéressant
petit nul petit nul nous forcément très
intéressant
non mais ça a bien joué mais non dommage
parce que peut-être maxwell
le planter un parent disant s'il ya bien
un type de position peut-être où il peut
le planter c'est quand c'est comme ça
avec magnus moan parti à city via qu'est
ce qu'un nom à 8 soit un petit via
casque quoi ça a l'air de jouer sur wii
non je laisse je laisse faire nul
attends je vais bien j'ai bien géré tout
le cadre est latent je suis un gentil
calme mais on n'ose y compris la ronde
et dans 5 minutes on est tranquille et
alex berson qui veut parler de messi
ballon d'or
non les échecs bah ouais bah quoi dire
bah c'est bien 6e ballon d'or hier faut
faire attention de ne pas trop tirer
dedans
non non mais je ne sais pas que je vois
les gens qui gueulent the wizard of many
ou quoi bah non en fait
bon mais aussi je dis non vas pas
pourquoi manet agence à ce qu'ils jugent
qu'il était très fort il a gagné plein
de trucs on savoir il joue à liverpool
déjà ce vers quoi
mais non les bons en battant vous
griezmann la pagani
quand il était champion du monde où
ribéry à l'époque où schnyder à l'époque
ou iniesta
non mais moi j'aurai bien j'aurais donné
à vendre dic mais le fils oh ouais mais
ouais ben écoute nord mais bon toujours
sympa de sa part fin je sais pas
pourquoi on en fait tout un flan ce
ballon d'ars en fait donné des
récompenses individuelles dans un sport
collectif déjà c'est un peu chelou est
un bon jour peut interpréter comme
tanguy ouais non c'est difficile mais
j'ai l'impression qu'il donne - prime à
l'équipe que avant sert clairement c'est
ce que tu disais c'est que tu avais
besoin de gagner la coupe du monde ou
gagner quelque chose
et du coup on fait ça récompense à un
peu le collectif en même temps
maintenant le collectif bac
quelque part ça comme tu dis c'est un
truc individuel donc pourquoi pas passer
ça un peu toi mais si wayne sur l'année
c'était sûrement le meilleur joueur donc
voilà après ça qui l'a pas gagné grand
chose à faire à part la bigorre
en fait oui parce qu'il ya une époque en
fait
pas si lointaine mais maintenant qu'il
est révolu c'est avec tu peux pas
acheter tout le monde qu'on va voir
toutes les stars dans ton équipe souvent
un mec un peu au dessus qui représente à
ton équipe dans l'inconscient collectif
oui tout cela ne leur a pas gagné mais
bon le fait qu'il soit là toi comme
maradona chebah platine mouvement ni
madeleine à milan à l'as est en fait
donc vrai qu'on sait à la fois l'équipe
est à la fois sa star mais maintenant
d'histoire dans l'équipe
donc c'est plus difficile des jarres
mais si pour le coup ils représentent
vraiment barcelone quoi en fait j'ai
l'impression que c'est un peu faim le
foot ça devient un peu comme olive et
tom starke au début tu avais tom dans
une équipe comme bordeaux ça s'était
jamais à brême où ils jouent tous
ensemble
tu sais plus quoi faire tap tap plus de
stars c'est très pénible bon tome quand
même toujours parce qu'enfin un moment
donné mais bon mark landers que tu as
les jumeaux dans tout le monde
ouais c'est horrible carillon apprête à
vue si les français avec la technique
mais c'est vrai que vont les autres
équipes sont moins forts disons un mec
ou de assez fort et des no name de
partout oui oui alors que mon au japon
quand même c'est une équipe de stars en
pierre mais surtout non mais c'est vrai
qu'elle est impressionnante leur équipe
avec 20 les jumeaux talent des recettes
à tom tu as le gardien génial à
merveille sa deux goals super foire quoi
ouais ouais c'est jay bruce le jeu puis
son nom on défend ce matin une grosse
équipe comme quoi c'est gênant mais
c'est un peu ça en fait maintenant le
foot c'est que tu as deux trois grosses
équipes mais bon cela reste beaucoup
plus fort que musicaux il a fait la
passe bien dans le tempo quoi et j'adore
j'étais tellement heureux quand le quand
le courant tu attends disait ce à quoi
ça s'est passé tellement du vlad tout
craché non ce jour ça quoi c'est
tellement book foutu prend le
contre-pied que le dire oui quel beau
but de messi non ben oui passe décisive
qui fait tout
vive le fait de dire je passe comme vous
l'a dit hier que tu veux n'importe quel
coût très mal jouer quoi oui tu n'as pas
pu répliquer au centre dès que les
équipes adverses ne font pas n'importe
quoi tu n'es plus capable de rien reste
est génial je regarde la partie je
regardais partie du truc féminin comme
nathan
accord parce que luna il entraîne la
gnose pas un secret et il regarde il me
dit oui non là ça ne va pas du tout
cette position du travail au noir sont
moins bien non ça va mais elle va jouer
si c'est sûr que oui enfin c'est quand
même ridicule que de faire à fils tu vas
tu affaiblir il dit t'inquiète je sais
bon juste un outil ma belle je regarde
on va là j'espérais justice quoi
maintenant depuis l'époque en tant que
c'est pas là il est parti entre harga
rdée mais il m'a dit je suis sûr qu'ils
auront 8 bien ce que je t'avais dit quoi
fin qui s'y connaît le x 4 direct mais
oui mais tu as tu tu n'as pas joué à 6
tu ne joues pas la rendre la plus
intéressant tu ne connais rien mais bon
c'est dans attache moi non mais c'est
tellement beau d'être assis avec vlad et
quand il allume son smartphone pour
regarder les parties d'échecs d'aï
critiques toutes tailles et toutes en
énerver c'est génial quoi mais c'est
beaucoup quoi alors on va peut-être un
peu dire bonjour au chat un petit peu à
tout le monde ce que l'on fait une
petite discussion avant 17h une question
de marc fans riquiqui m'a dit qu'est ce
qui se passe si quelqu'un gagne
aujourd'hui ce que ça continue de marc
whitten a raconté un haut qu'il arrive
il y avait quelqu'un qui doit se dire
quoi les 3.0 basse et trois points en
fait c'est le nombre de points qu'ils
ont pour l'instant battu mark iii pour
un laser 3 partout en fait la victoire
vaut 6 points en partie lente donc là
nulle 3 la moitié voilà après il y aura
les parties rapides
ce serait un peu moins et puis les beats
encore moins ce sera 6 4 et 2 6 4 et
devrait et du coup aujourd'hui tuchan
maxime favoris ou petit nul mais kenny
tonolito bah comme d'hab null null est
favori face à l'étoile est là nul tu
mets quelques hôtes on annule soit 1,30
à était pas généreux banon mais ils vont
aux échecs que jamais agi très haut sur
une nulle quoi ce serait beau de mettre
3 30 comme au foot ou tard j'ai encore
gagné toi donc très riche et voilà les
actions fdj
pour y couler à flots fdj en sueur face
aux nuls quoi s'en met au vert ces
actions ça flambe toujours nasa flambage
c'est par la fdj mais je sais que la
bourse descendez hier aujourd'hui sans
sueur salive déjà
mais s'il vous plaît à l'automne c'est
peut-être la fdj ça va me censure avec
trump qui veut qui veut remettre des
taxes sur les produits de luxe parce
qu'il fait qu'on a il veut mettre des
taxes de 100 % sur les produits français
quoi même à cause de la taxe goff
représailles
moi je te faire des taxes sur ces sacs
te merde mais pas de chance quoi ce
serait beau que ce à quoi je te taxe
mcdo dégager vite acheté nos billets
d'avion pour les états unis
non ça va taxer vite fait bien fait mais
sinon je t'interdis fabiani business qui
de rentrer sur mon territoire mais bon
c'est très bête avant à votre adn
ce serait beau quoi tu trouves
représailles dans la gueule traduire les
visages qui ne rentrera pas éthique ce
que faire maintenant c'est déjà les vul
daniel raid j'essaye de venir mois
dernier dresse je te l'interdît aussi
mais attention on verra bien quoi alors
on nous demande si ces rencontres
physiquement les joueurs ouais ouais ils
sont lisses rencontre physiquement ça va
dans l'autre
ouais on nous propose du g4 au premier
coup ce serait étonnant mais bon après
ça a fait ses preuves un conte kingston
a eu d'ailleurs vlad va raconter un truc
génial ce matin il m'a dit en fait à
l'époque de tes échecs romantique qui
faisait des bennes partisans voyait
partout ouais en fait il ya une raison
que je connaissais pas c'est que en fait
les mecs qui publiaient leurs partis
dans des journaux est en réalité c'est
un genre de type i fait c'est à dire
qu'il ya des fins ils avaient des
bienfaiteurs qui les envoie dans les
tournois mais en fait si tu faisais que
des parties pleutre comme ça aujourd'hui
avec des petites nul et où enfin même si
tu gagnes en fait à ce débat sponsorisés
à l'énoncé des gages en fait c'est une
m'intéresse pas donc du coup les mecs se
sentait un peu obligé de faire le
spectacle et du couple a dit oui c'est
peut-être ça l'esprit m'a dit si tu es
prêt déjà l'esprit à l'époque où tu as
des types si tu fais le beau jeu peu
ouais ouais c'est fait le beau je
l'aimais cachette revu regarde ces
parties même si tu perds peu
on a derrière un ballon de type faut
envoyer les gains du typique partout
ouais nan on touche le fond font
rebondir quoi à lui valent une belle
partie quoi ouais t'as dit art à mios
qui me dit qu'on va jouer ensemble un
blitz au choix de france 2 auxerre mais
je pense tu confonds sur la personne sur
le lieu parce que je suis jamais là
auxerre en fait non mais c'est vrai je
crois que tant 96h m france d'auxerre
elle promis que j'ai joué adultes 1 je
veux dire c'est 98 donc
donc voila mais bien tu vas trouver un
autre truc que tu te lâches une deuxième
grosse info mais les lads moi je sais
pourquoi on voit plus beaucoup de
berlinoises ah non pourquoi as tu ne
sais pas non tu veux leur faux bond une
info qualitative marque repère deux
premiers de première main donné au
niveau de la très très haut niveau
alpha 0 du coup il arrive à réfuter
manila plus tôt ouais c'est fini en fait
ça n'existe pas les blancs son jeu non
mais tout le monde sait en fait personne
n'a joué mais tout le monde sait qu ils
sont tous au courant et c'est pour ça
qu'en fait tu en vois beaucoup moins les
blancs sont mis à zéro et tout le monde
à lille à zéro maintenant en fait j'en
ai parlé cornetto à non mais v'là de
manille bombe a enfin fini enfin la
berlinoise
pas de chance mais pourquoi se faisait
rôle à jouer à fond et puis finalement
il a compris après coup high yield il a
dû la jouer la jouer après il a dû
s'asseoir avec lui même et se dire oui
en fait leur indicible
je me moque non mais peut-être qu'ils
ont juste avalisé fatwa j'ai pas les
détails des lignes et tout mais
peut-être qu'ils ont analysé plus loin
et qui sont dit qu'il y avait un
avantage quoi ça mais c'est marrant que
tu as pourquoi tout le monde sait en
même temps fait ça que j'ai ma copine a
pas un qui joue il s'est planté le truc
est aveugle et le monde au courant
vraiment à wheeling magic zip alpha 0
kevin source kevin ans et lille à zéro
c'est juste pas le faz héros je me suis
planté le nom mais bon c'est la même
chose pas quelle est la différence
mais en fait ils savent tous tout en
fait c'est marrant oui mais d'accord
mais enfin en gros lille a évolué en
même temps pour tout le monde pour leur
dire tous le même jour à c'est fini nous
joue plus un an ils analysent tous les
mêmes trucs en fait oui mais ça je
comprends
enfin ça marchait pendant 25 ans et du
jour au lendemain c'est fini pour tout
le monde le même jour ça veut dire c'est
bizarre allez on voit pourquoi jarre le
30 novembre
ah ça y est ils ont plein de nouveautés
ils savent que les autres les ont aussi
en fait oui ça joue ça et donc du coup
ils savent pas ils savent tous la même
chose mais parce que enfin des trucs que
je comprends pas c'est pourquoi ils ont
trouvé là maintenant aujourd'hui qu'en
fait et bah non en fait ils ont tous mis
à analyser avec le truc et puis tout
d'un coup ils ont trouvé bon bon écoute
du coup pendant la partie du jour non en
fait il n ya en ce moment de toute façon
dès qu'il ya une ouverture que tu vois
plus eu
[Musique]
c'est que c'est du lilas 0 en fait il
m'a dit en gros dés qu'il ya une
ouverture tu vois beaucoup moins à la
mode c'est que il y en a qui on analyse
avec lille à 0 ils se sont arrêtés de le
jouer du coup les autres ils se disent
oui c'est bizarre qu'il a arrêté de
jouer à gré sans même checker ils sont
sûrs que ça et du coup après il re
tchèque et voilà quoi mais c'est marrant
non
ouais ouais bon si tu fais confiance non
tu fais pas forcément confiance mais
juste après turcs parce qu'en fait ce
truc de lille à zéro le truc c'est qu'il
envoie ses analyses sur le cloud en
faites quoi qu'il en soit à tout le
monde
marie on peut du coup donc du coup en
fait si le redis commencent à comprendre
qu'il ya un mec qui est mieux en fait il
va comprendre en plus de parts toucher
tout le monde
ni boussole donc
mais lilo spa locale je crois que ça
tous les mois des infos mais de façon il
analyse les mêmes choses ensemble sur
les mêmes trucs code donc dans tous les
cas il arrive forcément même conclusion
ils ont les mêmes ordinateurs
il analyse les mêmes choses qu'est ce
que tu veux enfin c'est énorme et c'est
mathématique en fait et sinon pour la
partie des personnes qui avaient un
petit coup là il faut soit on se refait
la partie du couffo b5 ahvaz et la bombe
aux mains du cratère ni de phrases quoi
voilà du coup m
bon après l'étonnant que soit partie
civile non plus il ya de bons résultats
car le sable mais ok il joue ouais bon
cap si ce classique rock qui avaient
pris 4 à la vente ouverte de l'espagnol
dès 4 hélas le coup très rare fiat mais
en fait ils l'avaient déjà joué contre
caruana mais très rares fausses notes et
il faut jouer là dessus je sais pas ce
qu'il faut faire mais je retourne c'est
normal mais le trou cet engin toile et
non ils faisaient des cinq plus tôt
6e coup des 5 fu d3 et d5 parce que tu
peux pas vraiment joué puis on prend des
caps et a des soucis à base de taureaux
ont bien sûr mais ça on l'a déjà vu n'en
voit donc cette position-là précise si
on l'a déjà vu dans la région prend 2,5
fois aux 6es il ya des milliers de
parties entières de pagnol corchia il a
beaucoup joué
enfin on est plein de très bons joueurs
et des livres écrits dessus récemment ça
revient à la mode et ses solides
d'ailleurs pas bien on est d'accord que
la théorie elle va très très loin à sa
très loin après faut aussi ce qui peut
jouer plein de coubon c3 en général mais
tous choqués les deux tours avec des
modes autour des 1 g cloud 3 tu peux
faire c'est ok c'est un vaste sujet à
quoi jean mendez mais du coup ce qu'il a
choisi dans la partie des quatre fosses
est assez rare et ça s'entend un sa
crise de pions fait enfin au moins un
passager
parce que sur fos à tours 1 en fait
l'idée des noirs c'est de faire b 5
tata que fout exactement et jaar tour
prend 1,4 tu fais des 5 tu dégages la
tour donc le mec se barre avec sa tour
ouais alors taille intermédiaire qui lie
proulx 5,6 prend 1,4 on s'est fié aux
quêtes attaque la dame et le joug d'une
cookies et procès qui doit bouffer tout
reprend voilà tout reprend et b prend
1,4 et jarek et ces trois structures
gagner un pion mais c'est le genre de
truc où il y aura toujours deux contres
jeux etc les fous là on déjà parler de
ça aussi
peut-être qu'on a déjà commenté ce genre
partie comme je sais pas je crois qu'on
a déjà parlé mais peut-être en a parlé
entre nous pas dans une vidéo ok moi
j'en avais parlé vite feps en fait
c'était la première ronde des listings
du field entre naka et cajon ah ouais
donc aux couches comme je commentais
boumba gilali basé dessus
mais voilà en fait j'ai pas plus la fois
lâché bouger pas mal de trucs mais mais
du coup carlson l'a déjà joué caruana
aussi donc c'est gage de sérieux
du coup c'est ce qui se passe dans la
partie juste pour rebondir sur le chat
en fait même avec vlad quand on discute
ensemble ils à 0 souvent l'appel alpha 0
mais c'est juste la même chose tu vois
ça me fait penser aussi tu as un truc
dont on a souvent parlé avec toi avec
les joueurs amateurs et les pros genre
souvent connaît pas les noms précis des
ouvertures ont ce site les coûts mais on
connaît pas forcément le nom de la
variant de l'aele parents tu sais
comment s'appelle cette variante non
défense morphy mais j'entends suite mort
fille de ce panel ouverte
mais en fait je veux dire par là que ça
vient on va pas le savoir et quand on se
parle d'échec on se dit rarement enfin
tu allais souvent quand on parle avec
l'adq ont déjà la tête à leur ont parlé
longuement d'alpha 0 et en fait on
parlait de lille à zéro en réalité mais
je le redis récent avec les réseaux de
neurones gré ce boîte n'importe lequel
ce même chose qu'eux mêmes on parle plus
d'évaluations de position de machin tu
vois on parle plus de trucs précis quoi
sans s'embêter avec le langage
mais du coup des textos que fish tous
les programmes doubles ça s'est fini qua
non il fait les deux en fait ça ils font
tous les deux fait il a eu les deux en
même temps
mais suivant les positions il en utilise
plus l'un ou l'autre donc pas besoin de
machines très puissantes
pas vraiment parce que ça utilise lille
à 0 ils utilisent la carte graphique
oui ça s'affiche il utilise le
processeur donc en réalité non c'est ça
la vente
peut-être que sur mon ordi là il serait
pas si nul vu que c'est un an dit gamer
est dans ce sens gamer quoi mais oui
serait même si je me sens absolument pas
énorme
ouais ouais non mais il serait pas
mauvais back est forgé c'est adéquat
peut-être la révolution sans point et
l'eau qui arrive des nouveautés de
partout qui sait mais non il faut
comprendre aussi que lille à 0 aidé par
vlad ou un grand maître de premier plan
plus tough fiche ça se fait c'est plus
fort que lille à zéro tout seul en fait
donc face et par faut comprendre c'est
complètement différent fait mais ok
olimag benji qui me veut mouiller le
tout elle conseille je viens pas mathieu
m'avait expliqué un peu mais j'ai peu le
temps de fermer là dans la semaine où
est mon prochain je ferai mais si on
vire tuto ses volontés soit tu mens ou
un email ou de twitter ce que tu veux
est vrai comme ça il peut être admettre
et tu vas pas agresser de fou quoi notre
école non ça donnait mai dernier tournoi
à l'âge que j'ai depuis un moment le
dernier que j'ai fait est au maroc j'ai
fini second c'était bien côté de
marrakech
mais c'est ou d'être tout début du mois
à quoi donc enfin dumas dernier déjà en
tout cas ça doit être assez intéressant
de l'analyser avec peut donner
il est là mais bon après on y va de sa
fête ya pas mal de positions juste un
cliché plus fort en réalité met all-in
kinnig mdm ce soir sur twitter j'ai
quand même très attention will
rencontrons-nous dans un bar pour boire
un petit café que je t'aide à installer
lille à quoi on ne vous sous un pont
avec une clé usb etc peuple
donc du coup tu nous lâchent pas d'un
fossé après v prend 1,4 non en fait le
truc c'est que jean ça mais de feeling
jamais fonctionné pour les noirs sur le
peu que j'ai vu et voilà mais du coup
j'ai pas analysé avec l'ordi à fondre ou
quoi et le truc c'est que j'ai un truc
al sani très bien préparé un voyage et
ou tempo mais que max réfléchit un peu
donc qui j'ai l'impression que ça va
être dur de le planter
il est toujours dur à planter un nom
mais toujours mais je veux dire si en
plus il est correspondant sa prépa c'est
d'autant plus vrai que toi t'as pas trop
d'idées sur comment fêter le truc
vérifier obtenir une position
intéressante on demande si c'est la
partie la wii du coup c'est la partie
pas se régénère en fait qu'on regarde un
truc complètement différent qu'on ait
mis les noms en haut et en bas et
souffle quoi on se regarde on se regarde
propre truc quoi on met des petits messi
qui court qui font des frappes normes en
gros ce qui est ici dans la position si
les gens veulent du cac et ses trois
sauts logique mais il ya une tentative
walk et c3 ces deux dames 1 pour amerrir
leur en ligne assez logique aussi en
fait c'est un truc que je défends en
cours ou quoi tu as comme la partie de
steinitz contre von bergen ou quoi ou
tâte le fossat que c'est très bien je
fais tu de 6 alors ça ils font pas trop
alors je sais pas pourquoi ça c'est pas
remettre leur dit on fait quoi bon
apprendre que ces deux temps faut 6 4
d'autant que j'ai derrière le duo f4 qui
peut arriver
bon doit se défendre point noir mais bon
peut-être que c'est gionta sens-tu
forget 6 ou non mais il faut que tout
est petit ce même que dégage la tour ils
font grève cet été c'est pas très bien
avec un peu comme la partie 2 le style
du coup tous là mais tu serais content
car adam verdun pour les faires des
échecs à 5 ou des choses généralement
faut dire que quand tu as un fou de
cases noires des miroirs la dame sur
carte blanche sera bien ensemble alors
peut-être d'après même genre d'idée on
peut tenter dames 2e dames 1
je ne sais pas si ça si ça pourrait
améliorer mais ça peut être une
tentative
j'en sais rien six victoires en 3 et
puis du goûter je tape pas s'en va te
casser les couilles sur wattpad damage 5
va te faire j 6 mettra toujours damage
si ce qui est un peu chiant parce que la
tourache fille devient patron jeu alors
je sais pas s'ils n'en sais pas si toute
fois mais ça c'est pas le genre d'idée
pas toujours utiles je sais pas
peut-être dames de saintes et hâtive et
sinon en tout cas ce que les blancs ont
fait la plupart du temps c'est
simplement simplement kelly c3 mais du
coup les noirs vont rockets de faire le
front des six est bien passé leur permis
cette position-là déjà vu tout en d5
food et si son arrêt à minima par les
ensembles de ce truc là et tu me disais
oui ça ressemble un peu avec le fonds en
bessette qui arrive
marchal et du cou du coup c'est ça
l'enjeu de la variante est en fait s'il
demande assez fraîches intéressante a du
coup et la partie de double claque on
avait fait avec la nouveauté ou tu te
prononcer pas c'était en cale variantes
non c'est sûr à 4,6 anti marshall c'est
pas ça l'est encore autre chose alors on
court à cannes qui ne mangeait pas su au
final est mauvais les qualifiés aux
finales ou pas est fait de quoi acheter
c'est à dire mais bon je te laisse lâché
l'info quoi alors pas encore voilà non
mais en fait c'est un tournoi qui
n'arrive avec laquelle il faut qu'on dit
c'est des grandes chez ce tour donc
c'est honda privée c'est de l'exhibition
va dire la plupart complètement même nom
web pas ça rassemble pas mal les
meilleurs joueurs au monde a évidemment
et donc c'est déjà très bien d'être dans
les quatre premiers donc l'ajout admis
qu'une quarantaine etc
mais ça change absolument rien de gagner
ce tournoi de le perdre d'autres
qualifié de pas être qualifié les
candidats c'est un autre circuit et ça
se jouera dans dix jours un peu moins
d'ailleurs à jérusalem est donc pour
l'instant d'en bas qui m'a plutôt les
cartes en main il est bien placé mais
alors faire faire un bon tour m'enfin ok
pas faire bien pire que ben mehdi of
honey pot en tout cas je vais faire un
tour de moins pour résumer si tu fais
deux tours de moins t'éliminer su faire
augmenter qualifié en gros faut au moins
aller en demies ok s'il va en finale
c'est je pense c'est fait il va là prêts
à perdre au premier tour ce tous les
autres perdent au premier tour ça peut
le faire aussi
merdre premier d'autres perdre au
deuxième mais aussi d'ailleurs voilà
donc en fait envoyé pas mal mais rien
n'est fait il a son destin entre les
mains puisque ça dépend que de lui pas
des autres c'est pas comme si on se dit
ah merde si m'hamed afghane au tournoi
alors oui et non
alors tu sais que oui et non parce que
si mamediarov gagne le tournoi et qui
bat maxime en finale il est assez
probable que ce soit mamediarov qui se
qualifier oui d'accord mais tu as quand
on descend très original mais passons
c'est la fin
je veux la paix la mégère en fait
mamediarov peut dire la même chose
mammadov a mis d'accord à tout le monde
a son destin entre les mains quoi c'est
génial mais oui je suis d'accord avec
toi mais c'était pour te contredire pour
faire du débat tu vas pas de la
polémique marie toi je veux faire le
buzz mais donc du coup de faire ils ont
à répondre à votre question dans quinze
jours non mais ce sera bien quand même
dans deux semaines on pourra dire oui
les qualifiez vous n'auriez pas qualifié
enfin bon bien oui les qualifiés quel
plaisir voilà enfin ça fait un an et
demi que ça dure qu'on ne peut pas
répondre que la plupart des tournois ne
sont pas qualificatifs qu'on n'en peut
plus en fait oui en fait appeler
joue-t-il le genre du monde où il faut
qu'il y ait le joueur des candidats
commencé type n est ce que le grand
duché sur et qualificatif au match pour
le titre de champion du monde s'inquiète
pas quoi même en fait en gros faudrait
écrire un écriteau tout le temps qu'ils
abandonnent qui passe le grand
l'histoire ne sert à rien et ça parce
que le temps tu as ça ne te qualifies
pour rien et ça passe tout le temps
après nous on était des grands avocats
en revanche fo faut le souligner du du
fait de faire tient de merdier les
circuits et de faire un gros circuits à
l'année où tous les coups tournera
contré par contre on dit toujours le
grande chaise tour compte pas le grand
pied de son point bas et peut-être les
gens ils se pensent qu'on est anti
grande chez sourds ou quoi ce n'est pas
le cas nous on serait plutôt fage pape
je parle pour toi mais parce que je sais
que tu es d'accord on sait en fait que
pour tous ces tourments il compte en
fait tout au long de l'année et que ce
soit un vrai circuit complet et ça ce
serait cool en fait ouais bien sûr
donc c'est bien que non mais en fait que
ça compte en soit ce serait logique
ça semblait mieux romont après bon ben
ali sont pas mis d'accord et puis du
coup ils sont piette dessus avec les
calendriers
ouais je finis juste avant des fouilles
de mettre des tournois pendant aux
essais pas très simple fins
pour l'instant les à la gueule c'est pas
bon sur ce bassin mais ça reste un
tournoi exhibition dont on dit qu'ils
empiètent sur un tournoi qualificatif en
titre de champion du monde qui est le
truc ultime
oui oui tu dois faire place plutôt au
titre de champion du monde au circuit
pour le titre de champion du monde que
pour le grand show ce tour même si ça
semble beaucoup de joueurs qui a
beaucoup d'argent que c'est très suivie
et c'est que c'est plutôt bien organisé
d'ailleurs mais parce qu'après ça donne
des cas bizarre où tu as des joueurs qui
sont malades une semaine avant les
tournois et kiffa qui joue le grande
chaise sur long
mais qui sont malades par anticipation
sa trace dans une semaine sur les
malades c'est là mais en fait ce qu'il a
donné comme excuse c'est sûr c'est moins
pas de métier qui m'a rien fait mais
globalement il serait pas faux plat en
course pour vérifier non mais non mais
en fait enfin c'est toujours très vite
que tu va toujours trouver une excuse
empathie c'est ça ben oui j'ai un petit
peu mal au petit doigt de pied je dois
me faire en père est un nom qu'on
appelle ça c'est les ondes incarne un
homme incarné un bon ça tombe enfin tu
as toujours trouvé un truc en fait
puis surtout que si tu as des problèmes
respiratoires la capitale londres tu
vois je suis pas sûr que ce soir mais en
droits réer
je pense que s'il a un truc pas si grave
mais un peu chiant et donc là en fait ça
empêche pas de jouer mais vu que restons
jérusalem se sert à lire absolument rien
pour lui il se dit bon bah je peux le
rater ya pas de problème donc voilà
c'est juste qu'en battant non non mais
j'aime pas trop enfin je sais pas après
mais j'aime pas trop le fait de prendre
feu ya des gens qui sont vraiment
malades sur terre et je trouve que
prendre d excuse médicale mise bidon
après ça se fait dans tous les sports
dans tous les trucs mais je trouve ça un
peu membres non bah oui enfin moi je
pense en fait quand un engagement tu
veux retenir non puis surtout que le
truc médical c'est un peu plus neutre
quoi tu vois non mais surtout que tu
peux y aller tu fais deux nuls tu perds
le rapide je rentre chez toi de deux
jours en fait ou alors fallait pas
s'engager au début ou machin mais non
mais tu sais pas c'est juste la limite
de l'organisation la de la fidh en fait
de chasse pour ces pour les qualifs
c'est qu'en fait comme c'est une série
de tournois en fait c'était très mal
parti tu sais que tu vas pas de
qualifier et bat a juste permis
d'alléger le gars nous parce que ça sert
objectivement rien et c'est pour ça
qu'ils aronian n'ira pas jouer en avocat
en invoquant là la cause médicale qui
est qui est cependant vrai mais c'est
vrai que s'il était encore en course
wheeler est pris sur lui
donc radjabov paradjanov pareil ouais
donc c'est un petit peu l excuse mais
dit-il c'est utile tu peux tu peux tu
peux toujours la prendre pour tous et
plus tôt il aurait pu dire en france
qu'il était en dépression que la limite
je suis dépressif jeu va venir mais mais
mais oui mais non c'est un peu un peu
triste quelque part non je trouve web à
s'effacer après je peux comprendre déjà
au tennis c'est pareil quand il ya trop
d'accidents sous le sigle fatigué ou si
vous lancez pas le problème mais m
mais là en fait ok c'est assez rare aux
échecs et puis je comme je dis je pense
tu vas tu peux aller faire un tour et
rentrer quoi ouais ouais non mais
j'étais juste un peu triste parce que
j'aime lire aronian tu vois donc je
m'attendais pas un coup tordu de sa part
tu vois ce que je veux dire non mais
après c'est juste que je pense
les dates l'arrangeait pour se repérer à
ce moment là et il ya du vrai dans ce
cas raconte mais je veux dire c'est sûr
que je suis quasi sûr qu'il aurait pu
prendre soin ouais ouais
après sur pareil c'est la presse le pas
dire à 100% j'ai pas vu ces examens
gratuits mais de le voir là à londres en
ligne la semaine prochaine là par contre
ne seront pas absolument sehic
sexuellement
c'est quand même possible de jouer ce
sera plus confortable de ne pas jouer se
faire opérer et donc voilà nos fans
demandent si la partie et on se pose en
fait enfin oui et non non sa maxime de
jouer mais réfléchit il a deux heures
donc prend son temps falco ensuite d'un
mode de vie ici bas on en a parlé d'un
me 2,1 fab famille et que ça paraisse
être un coup intéressant après c'est sûr
que ça a été analysé par magnus donc ces
chasses un peu comme l'âge 5 qu'il
allait pour ceux qui ont vu le mais là
pour le coup tu vas te voir tu vas
devoir jouer un coup forcément évident
oui mais peut-être d'un menu ce que tu
as le plus analysé quand même nom est tu
joues pour pour pour quelque chose qui
donne après
me2 du coup à ce qu'il faut aussi sa
fille 4f 600 moins bon même si c'est
peut-être possible
après tu es une autre option aussi cette
percée 6 to race est une rock star
donc du coup trois ans tu vas ok mais
bon peut-être à des baies 3 x 3 dès que
je sais pas mesdames de clarens ça peut
être une question enfin les noms doivent
montrer quelque chose mais bon pour le
coup je suis sûr qu'il l'a quelque chose
en réserve
non mais c'est sûr qu'il a tout analyser
la fin d'un jeu de dames et un cavalier
c3 c'est les 3 coups que tu envie de
regarder ma cave et gb 3par du coup il
ne va sûrement pas faire ce n'était pas
un coup très athlétique de bain
coûterait entre les titres en fait t'as
rien comme l'e3 c'est quoi donc il est
peut-être qu'il ya idées oui je voulais
que leur dit vous êtes de faire ça ça et
foix iii et il y avait eu dans la partie
c'était comme étroit il avait laissé il
a du jus ce troc et je crois qu'à roanne
un truc extraordinaire c'est que la
digue il annule mauvais résultats il
aurait fallu essayer de gagner je vous
plais 3 quoi ce type n'est pas un
athlète du coup vous l'a dit oui mais
non il faut il faut absolument gagner en
longues parce qu'après en rapide dans
blitz magnus gros favori à gauche pas
non mais c'est génial parce qu'après le
live jeudi à vlad mais tu es sûr de ce
que tu as dit enfin pour moi ces bons
résultats et tout ça on est sûr sur la
terrasse chez moi et bien du nid non
mais tu es fou en tie-break au départage
magnus et gros favoris en rapide j'ai
dit mais c'est pas des tie-breaks quoi
je dise il va y avoir des graffitis
think it's quoi quoi qu'il arrive il m'a
dit ah mince j'avais oublié
[Rires]
j'étais mort mais c'est génial comme
suit je voulais dit deux fois pendant le
live et tous mes plates c'est génial il
donne son avis il est très chaud et
toulon tu as tort après sûr et après sur
la terre à lui en fouillant fait du coup
tu avais raison quoi j'aime à l'antenne
j'avais à l'antenne bon écoute effet
rock faut à 3 fou prend là et vous tu y
joues l'idée de ouais alors en fait pour
le coup je ne vais vérifier et caruana
ffu aussi sur b3 mais bon rock ça vient
d'être nommé d'ailleurs d'ajouter mme
poux comme celle là il connaît encore là
c'est sur ces sujets de ça va être la
position elle est intéressante mais
obligés de connaître afin que les noirs
parce que c'est soupçonnant quoi
honnêtement vu le scénario de la partie
je pense ça n'a pas duré très longtemps
écoute c'est dure pas très longtemps je
pourrais jouer à la belote ce soir on
regardera peut-être un peu d'udine quoi
du coup
ouais quand même un petit peu quand même
si on va rester sur mac c'est autre
chose un petit peu histoire de voir de
voir quand même un peu d'échecs quoi
c'est un peu dommage donnant bien mais
du coup demain demain de demain les
rapides et l'hybride c'est tout la même
journée où c'est que des rapides et
c'est tout en même temps y aura le
speech s en même temps il ya tout en
même temps demain 20 ouhlala de partout
c'est à dire comment ça marche en fait
j'ai écrite chalabi bomba qu'est ce
qu'on fait on commande quoi vaiana
cadoudal jeunes à kaduna avons géré
quand même ils m'ont dit du coup tu
commentes tout entre deux multiplexes de
partout quoi donc ça va être génial oui
toi tu es nul fajr à vlad quoi oui tu as
de faire de très gros zéro rapide c'est
quoi être pendus à tiendra encore plus
nul que les autres taka ne comprend rien
cette fois pâtissent demain c'est ça
être génial calquer leurs vacances n'a
qu'à d'houdain je crois c et 18 heures
lassé de cette somme
c'est quoi le message est extraordinaire
c'est extraordinaire oui lesquels sont
les plus nuls d'après toi kiev quoi
beaucoup je ne sais pas à quoi je le dis
vous est très faible des deux côtés
[Rires]
oui je n'ai jamais vu ça quoi baver
était tellement de punch line quoi c'est
génial on regardait aussi un peu le
championnat d'europe féminin du coup
rapide et bim qui a gagné alors tout ça
continue je vais gagner un truc son
entraînement ouais du coup j'en refais
la demande des parties machin et après
il me demande à moi et il me dit qu'ils
avaient ce que tu penses qu en bonne
forme dans ce tournoi je fais 11 sur 11
ou dix émissions
est-ce que je laisse une nulle à
quelqu'un on pas qu enfin sachez sièges
c'est ma difficile mais je pense que les
gens n'imaginent pas que en fait passer
du temps avec la ddt c'est se prendre
des punchline comme il fait en live mais
à cheval au khalife de pire quoi peut
être fier c'est que ça que des punchline
tout le temps c'est extraordinaire en
fait
lionel en sueur quand on se prend des
punchline sur punchline aussi quoi c'est
fou ah ouais mais pour le coup un cadeau
date en pense quoi
je pense tout bas favori non non je peux
aujourd'hui notre club favori mais que
diop le limier non je pense pas je pense
pas je pense tout accroc favori quand
même hein on verra à margaux je crois
que c'est un schéma si j'ai une connerie
bamena qu'à mon avis il a perdu aucun
match en tata par contre magnuson
ouais ça tous les 13 ans je sais pas
mais je veux dire depuis un bon moment
là non mais c'est vrai mais bon je peux
pas ne pas lâcher cette enfin quoi non
non non non il n'a aucune chance
imax avis donc j'étais sorti par sow et
donc n'a qu'à duda c'est quoi ces 1/4
finale ouais et ils joueront après ils
joueront après jour après jour après
contre les pots mais je pense n'est pas
en dessous des deux en fait bizarrement
d'accession en plus les pauvres quand
est-ce qu'il va jouer sa demi de speech
est ce parce que du 10 au 24
il a le grand prix ouais et puis après
il ya le rapide et beats je viens du
monde
ouais qui se jouera à moscou d'ailleurs
et je viens c'est bien crois que j'ai
entendu qui se jouera dans le stade
loujniki
quand tu dois connaître buts 16 carey et
c'est là que mais comment sont ils vont
mettre un toit et où je me suis
recherche sur la pelouse mais c'est là
que vous l'équipe nationale de russie au
foot mais je crois à l'amour voilà c'est
l'extraordinaire en fait c'est génial
avec leurs kits bruits de klaxon là dans
les tribunes
soit on devrait y aller et on gueule
allez les verts affronteront cnr whist
en snack drastique mais s'il m'installe
devant un truc bien pas pour toi et je
pense oui je pense on a quasiment y
aller faire un visa et égaux ego faire
n'importe quoi donc j'ai crevé à
lisbonne plutôt toi même même le même
climat qua non mais c'est beau aussi en
ont donné je sais pas on va à une mue en
milieu change et du monde si on fait le
camp il appelle striking coûts/revenus
quoi
naka tu n'es pas un athlète mais la cave
à jazz vocal gaulle et d'un cadet pas un
athlète nu pendant ton cas d'échec à
fond quoi on fait un peu comme notre ami
qui avait fait pendant le championnat de
france d'échecs
ck championnat temps à caen et metz
thibault sylvie loiseau quel génie on va
faire un nul contre les gens quand il
t'arrive faire du le conte d'hoffmann
enfin il voulait faire mieux contre
d'orphan d'ailleurs et oui il voulait
venir sur sa soirée proposée duels vont
pas de chance il avait déjà fait nul
donc il attablé vite bon bah il est
quand même sur sanne quoi mais on n'a
pas pu proposer nul et c'est tellement
beau c'est que tu sais que j'ai joué une
fois contre dorfman en partie longue
fait nul bourriche
[Rires]
j'ai pas réussi à gagner mais il devra
battre ouais mais j'allais raconter il
partie extraordinaire même parce que je
sais donc donc fab
soyons sérieux voilà monde attend après
tout remise en fait non mais je n'étais
pas là faut que je la sais que ça va ça
va pas mal pour les noirs
est ce que tu penses que le niveau de
cette partie et descend pour le moment
non mais c'est très normal
pour le moment ça reste à faire la nique
à deux pas de chance on va dire c'est
que max s'est plutôt fait surprendre
dans le show d'ouverture de carlson et
carlson est en plein dans son île peut
réciter tranquillement et maxime doit
trouver une petite idée pour créer un
peu des problèmes pratiques sans rentrer
dans les rangs trop compliqué ont
d'ailleurs en jambes et 3 c'est ce qu'il
a fait il n'a pas joué les ventes ou
gagne un pion mais avec les avec le
contre je dois avec du cahier à 3 qui
prend 1,4 ou quoi ou les dames de ouled
ameur ça c'est clair c'est du très
concrets et en faisant b3 bon tu nuit
géante de piètres l'échiquier tu joues
et peut-être sur la structure ou quoi
mais laissez-moi ambitieux comme choix
mais après je comprends que tu ris pas
tu te prends un mur est en train de
préparer non je peux comprendre aussi
même et du coût probable nul coiffées de
fins c'est ça le le mauvais côté entre
guillemets comme une ombre
après tu penses que il a des bonnes
chances en rapide en bits
je pense qu'il peut il peut il peut le
mettre en danger un pas moins bonne
qu'en l'on veut te même média renom bas
ok t'es dur dans toute façon au carlton
c'est juste le meilleur avec les
cadences ça c'est un fait
après peu importe mais maxime en fait un
blitz s'il est en forme mais je pense
il n'y a pas tant que ça prend forme il
a eu le temps de repos mais il est tout
à fait capable de le battre et puis
récemment en plus il l'a battu assez
souvent quoi j'ai si souvent
donc il a sa chance viens on regarde un
peu ce qui se passe chez les autres
nazis
c'est quoi ce dîner avec les blancs
contre les vannes tu laisses jouer donc
une news aux ventes robin stein ouais il
se dit oui je vais jouer option isolé
bah c'est l'équivalent en quoi les
structures mais il a plus le temps de
faire h3 food et que le flou viennent
bref oui ça n'apporterait pas cette
position mais ça c'est juste égal nom
est égale grave non bon ben c'est un
tout petit peu mieux pour les blancs
mais genre de truc que tu presses jamais
non le plus globe qui pour avoir monté
un avis ferme là dessus que moi mais à
vue d'oeil je vois pas le danger pour le
vent tu as vu le chapitre sur les
échangeant des cinq ans
ouais non mais en fait je sais que tu
vas je crois que le fonds s'est vite et
qu'en plus tu transvase des pièces en
troisième tt bien puis on avait fait une
vidéo de deux minutes sur la chaîne en
plus oui avant même que de ce déjeuner
we have an avant mais là en fait oui vu
clé n'auront pas prendre de foot cases
blanches qui peuvent te l'échangé avec
du fou g6 michael si je réussis arrête
une pression très concrètes sur des cinq
rapidement jean rouger 5 sa part être le
truc très concret pour attaquer j'ai
même pas vu c'était premier couple
l'ordi est ok là tu fous ces trois plus
ou moins forcé b à c on doit faire
bouger si ce jeu sans sa ceinture juste
que tu veux
ouais tu vas faire flouer si ça va faire
a juste news je dirais quoi
d'ailleurs c'est impressionnant dans les
punchline de vlad juste comme on n'a pas
grand chose à dire on déjeune tu vois
genre de la soupe et tous vont envoyer
un petit temps mort on parle de rien et
vlad tout d'un coup me sors tu sais quel
c'est incroyable à quel point mort tu as
ne connaît rien c'est juste comme ça
gratuitement que pour le dialogue est en
train de manger genre juste va tu
savoures ta soupe de qualité feu c'est
incroyable à quel fond mur tu as ne
connais rien en fait ça fait très peur
aussi que je me dis bon mais tout juste
je vois jamais vlad filât
bonjour c'est pas si mal ce codage
risque de décès chez elle c'est gratuit
je souffrais bagdad un truc
extraordinaire extraordinaire et ne rien
connaître arrive à 2400 ses impressions
oui mais ça c'est typiquement ce qui
peut dire ne rien connaître et de 1730
mah il a fait prisonnier de prison 8 et
camani bien peut-être natation avant de
réciter ce qui a valu à trois bons ils
espèrent jeux taurins il passe le
piégeage et met à l'heure du couvent des
dames soit tu peux pas faire ce genre et
à bab il veut pas pour le moment dans le
sens où ça tu vas sûrement de faire un
jour mais pour l'instant c'est tu sais
quoi avant d'étendre leur dis j'ai vu le
truc de fou et 5 je pense est assez
logique en fait un nom mais en fait 20
contre si tu peux faire marcher d'un me
sentais que mon action 90 oui si tu
voyages
oui à la base c'était logique 5 et là
dessus surtout à damas fuites comme
celles ci c'est si je sais pas lequel
des deux deviendra viance à six mois
ouais c'était ma première idée des bas
juste en fait enfin entre guillemets de
qui veux dire ma 3 tu te défends
toujours ton pion à 4 as tu déjà enfoncé
trois peut-être fera à bab tu vas fera
du à 5 tours b vite machin mais non mais
mais ça va juste quoi du ku'damm d2 wen
outre cinq sérologique
bon au moins ils seront pas une réponse
tempo au moins voilà ce coup était bien
trop faible pour que je l'analyse que
non mais oui il faut f5 justement 9,5 ce
normal
qu'est-ce qu'il ya d'autres dames c6
direct aussi non noël se chante on
regarde mais bon tu t'es tu te fâche et
non en fait non je vis est ce que tu te
dis que sur b a du coup tu veux pas le
jour en deux coups et en fait tu t'en
fiches non non ça va mais peut-être que
c'est parce que en fait j'ai du mal à
imaginer comment les blancs peuvent être
mieux ici je vois juste pas de cas de
figure où ça va bien se passer 1
mais quand même ça qu'on ne peut pas
tenter d'amener cas tu voir si on a un
peu ambitieux à la pâte pour sa soeur de
m6 de megan est ici ouais on peut
peut-être mais alors tu veux qu'on mette
dame ces six dames b4 tournée d'adieux
aussi par un sosie aucun problème au
regard de la haye là et je réside
peut-être d'am dam de tours
je montre un pur ouais mais oui ici on
fait du retour 18 hockey donc je prends
à 4 sinon ça fait aucun sens voilà du
coup je veux jouer la finale et tours 2
les blancs ont rien ici c'est sûr même
lent 29 on souffre ouais
pis ils souffrent donc du coup ces
retours eux adam c6 d'amd 4 ok non
ok elle a fait juste a b ab à 5 à 4
ouais non mais voici à bab on est
d'accord
oui ça lundi inquiète a pas d'âme v5 ce
que je touche ces deux way et puis il
n'y a pas d'histoire de maths du couloir
ou coop ce sont là quelques 8
donc tu recules en d2m là c'est déjà
assez confortable en fait prévu et même
même fou aussi sur pattes cassées non
mais même alors il n'y a aucun problème
n'ont même plus qu'il ya trois vraiment
non mais le mot existe vraiment en fait
oui mais un tank adverse non mais en
tant que parent donc ses smart s'y
présenter moi je te dis quand même temps
pour objectif il a fait faute 5
bouteilles d'eau vides
oui mais bon c'est quand même très
logique c'est un peu un ami dans le
métier est alors allons réfléchir et
hockey de pub du coup peut-être dame c3
oui t'empêche pas d'amener ans et si ça
tu attaques un peu ses sept
du coup bon peut-être qu'on peut quand
même faire dame cette main à oui c'est
vrai tape b a manqué ce truc mais tour
v8
voilà peut-être je veux dame b 4 ou tour
b 4
j'aime pas tout simple tous les regards
en fait je voulais montrer à remettre au
passage qu'on a un ça va
en fait je voulais jouer ça juste pour
montrer un dans la sarthe basket hourly
matinée si la matza va pas même s'il ya
pas match mais juste ont montré un truc
bizarre avec le cavalier c'est qu'on
peut l'enfermer sur a3 il faudra faire
gaffe à ça non la feria mais du coup
peut-être fait pas trois minutes dans
notre 17e
bien qu'ils sont bien d'autres tendue
qu'on donne le ton pour tout remettre
mon déjà d'autres peut-être tours 8
ce cavalier bouge pas et c'est un
problème
bon je sais pas trop vite sinon la saint
avit tant pis on faisait la bonne
colonne après une maigre comme h5 que ya
pas de maths du couloir peut-on a fait
rage 4 un truc
ils seront vingt sound par logica les
dames dissipe à tout moment et du coup
on va tomber vitrine elle m'avoue
prochain ouais on fait un peu du hk
tâche 3 alpha 0 quoi ouais voilà on
verra enfin tu as on sait bien touché au
pied gauche parce qu'il n'ya pas de matt
reeves diable donc tous à quatre nous
qui chipe à courir non mais le truc moi
ce que je veux vraiment souligner c'est
le cavalier non pays bas il est triste
et ok donc avec l'élan est ce qu'on
arrive un jour à jouer ces quatre pour
le ramener manière plus ma tête vous
allez si nous luttons tant directs
peut-être tour 1 dames c'est 6 et 4 ok
du coup le nord qu'est ce que tu en
penses tu
déjà première question est ce qu'on peut
juste prendre prendre prendre mais j'ai
pas envie d'un charmant conte peu de
gens fêtent le vent est enfin j'ai envie
de te dire c'est un peu un cavalier
annuel non sa sortie de tristes ce que
kamal ben quoi c'est pas demain mais tu
peux prendre plus de cavaliers en c4 tu
te ramène pas bon après tout dire oui
mais enfin pourquoi c'est pas les noirs
qui sont mieux fou contre cavaliers jeu
sur deux à elle je fais fausse this way
non mais ok je je je voulais faire des
cinq intermédiaire il a fait tout en
tout cas pour saddam c6 c7 c6
si adobe guise et suspicieux suspicieux
le bon mot oui mais bon mon seul salaire
assez soupçonnons comme aux jeux sortent
moins bien que fait on rigole on rigole
mais il ya des mots comme ça genre par
exemple tu sais les jeunes pour l'argent
et qu'ils l'avaient la cua délavé t'as
jamais entendu ça non je parle au club
des jeunes en reste écouter ntm beaucoup
à l'époque
en fait c'est un mot russe dargaud qui
veut dire argent ne puissent même pas
vraiment comment est peut-être en
français dix dès l'aube et peut-être
même mais a juste moi comme je prononce
à la russe ça fait plus la prononciation
française du truc mais
ce qu'en fait le haut souvent ils se
prononcent à henri ce sachet peut-être
enfin entre les deux mon peu importe
mais à mais du coup c'est un mot qui
vient du risque comme on dit miss lova
lova en russe non mais là ils disent
miss lova lova russie parce que c'est
une traduction de l'anglais en fait mais
bon si tu devais dire avec les bulls
russe c'est une gueule heure dont 7 en
fait c'est un truc entre le haut et le à
que tu dis du coup passé suivant ou et
l'accent du mans fin plus le haut est
proche de l'accent du mot puisse se
prononce au plus il est loin puis se
prononça et quand il est pas trop loin
mais pas trop près ils se retrouvent et
se prononcera quoi genre de ballon doit
suspicieuse c'est plus un mot courant
les gars je te le dis car je vois les
yeux de mon fils quand je lui ai dit je
sais pas ce qui est non monsieur je
rencontre rarement de façon
bref c'est très souvent comme mai mais
oui donc du coup tu as vraiment des mots
russes qui sont rentrés dans le lexique
français ou bistrot par exemple le
bistrot ce féru ce bistrot ça veut dire
vite en russe euh non je vois vite ton
café paul couet baies netapp a le temps
qu'enfin bis - et tu vois la pareille en
fait ça va se dire plutôt bis trahan
russe parce que c'est le haut qui à la
fin du coup il a pas d'accent du tout
face à aux relégués tu vois nul en ligue
2 ouais c'est un ou de ligue 2 20 juteux
lui a directement fait dégage je veux
pas voir ta gueule quoi prescrit pas
tout court s'écrie oh et suivant les
accents sont les régions pas des mecs
qui le liront haut quand même malgré ces
comme en espagne sur la je ne tente pas
le même accent et ils ne vont pas même
pas de compte et les mots tout à fait
pareil l'ambition c'est déjà assez vite
ou rapide mais en tout cas c'est un mot
russe je sais pas comment ça se traduit
exactement ces victoires rapides mais
mais oui donc tu as ta des mots russes
dans le vocabulaire français
la ville de versailles j'imagine tu as
beaucoup de mots français en russe en
revanche eu vraiment beaucoup moeurs
vraiment vraiment beaucoup
tu as beaucoup plus de mots france en
russe que russe en français mais il aime
bien votre nom à ille-sur-têt les
heureux vainqueurs même musée musée dans
la plainte par l'agent pense je pense
juste à un mot mais y'en a vraiment
beaucoup
j'ai même une fois qui veut gagner des
millions ils étaient très très mal que
je vais arriver dès n'y a ni des
millions à la maison bombe a fait un
mort médical à blatt c'est quoi bon bah
oui c'est une ablation je sais
exactement ce que ça veut dire mais les
mecs et en sueur où ils réfléchissent à
fond vous la question à 50000 euros
pas de chance vous connaissez mon avenir
votre langue que moi c'est une ablation
les mecs ne savait pas quand il dit oui
c'est du vocabulaire médical personne ne
savait oui c'est juste un mot français
mais bon nous on s'adapte on défend très
bas même moi juste heureux dit mais
c'est une ablation que oui c'est bon
sens avec n'importe quel étrange incarne
importe quel français aurait répondu que
c'était en fait à placer ce n'est pas un
faux ami
c'est un vrai ami et ma femme un petit
truc marrant aussi sur petite anecdote
marrante sur les mots france en russe et
un mot en russe âgé otages
c'est peut-être raconté quant à cannes
maintenant âgé otage c'est un mourut ce
qui veut dire
comment traduire ça en français du coup
quand un produit quand quelque chose des
très attendus les gens sont très heureux
moments où ça arrive et ça crée
de l'enthousiasmé au moment où ça sort
ou c'est pas genre les joueurs de de
saint-etienne sortent du du couloir il
arrive sur le stade et là tu arrives en
ag otage des supporters tu vois quand il
sort deux vestiaires sort du vestiaire à
40 sur le statut african manager otages
et du coup on fait comme c'est
clairement un mot qui revient du
français puisque ça se livraient mois la
haye voilà c'est ça c'est un peu genre
un engouement live voilà et c'est un mot
clairement qui vient du français face à
sa peur de venir d'une autre langue en
gros et du coup ma femme quand elle
était en france elle arrivait tous et
dès qu'il y avait un truc un peu comme
ça avait de l'engouement il assurera
ouailles à un brossage et otages tu vois
bon les gens du ils disent oui bon ça
sonne français on sait pas trop ce
qu'elle veut dire mais genre juste après
seulement 2 3 ans elle a fini par
comprendre ce que quelqu'un lui et enfin
moi je lui ai dit en fait mais c'est par
un beau france en fait personne ne te
comprends quand tu dis ça et elle était
choquée quoi mais du sprint on pense
alors j'ai otages est je pense que c'est
ça vient du français quand même que je
suis âgée otages mais jourd'hui de du
français agiotage c'est un truc qui
existent le faire dans google c'est une
spéculation malhonnête ou illicites sur
les cours de la bourse
une sorte de spéculation peut-être ça a
changé de mot ça a changé de sens à
notre âge des otages mais la région âgés
y âgées ou quoi toi c'est vrai mais
peut-être que 10 ag aum et de bastareaud
et puis quand ils ont un peu changé le
mot parce que toi musées musée guise pas
amusé et dix musées y tu vois musées
musée il ne faut pas confondre
spéculation et agiotage attention à la
fédération tu vas faire des amalgames la
sat est très très mal partie jeux sont
un sujet très glissant je lis je sais
pas enfin bon peu importe je sais pas
d'où ça vient mais tout ça pour dire que
il ya même des mots français qui se
retrouvent en rusant nous mêmes nous ne
comprenons pas ta david mcafee ils
égalisent pasqua va on à la partie la
plus insipides possible normes
enfin bon mais je sens qu'il va faire
ses 4 max en fait je sais pas mais c'est
une pression qu'on a regardé en fait
c'est ça qui est dur en fait on parle
beaucoup d'autres choses mais les trucs
qu'on regarde ça arrive mais avoir
beaucoup d'autres choses ouais un truc
c'est qu'on a vu ça on a vu ça on a vu
ça on a vu ça on a vu ça mais ça ça va
être juste également les blancs et les
noirs pardon oui mais se donne m'annonce
à tadic à ce quoi ça va contre manny ça
peut être semi relou quoique voitures
met la toile enseignants trois champions
non mais ça va pas complètement ravi qu
il est bon mais ça va ouais on
manquerait plus que ça à l'époque un
scoop foutu ecublens mes lordi propose
b4 10 to make bah je sais pas je trouve
ça moche bekkat après peut-être ça va
c'était d'ailleurs en fait ouais mais
les cases blanches
oui mais je veux faire du h5 et
compagnie je veux ces trois cas y ces
deux car il est là non mais vous vous
êtes arrivé que le car ayant eu 3
pourquoi pas en fait mais bon on va y
arriver des clauses buy en c2
d'apprendre à cinq quand même l'élection
double est ok si vraiment tu fais b4
sais que tu en fais ça tu dois pouvoir
tenir mais que tu commences déjà te
mettre en position
tiens je peux te dire une petite fille
qu'on est là dedans je veux dire une
petite expression russe sur sur ta
réaction après le coupé 4 noeuds
mode carapace de tortue envoie cette
expression tu regardes ce coup comme
lénine regard d'un bourgeois
c'est une expression reprise vraie
expression quand tu regardes un truc un
peu bizarrement que tetris soupçonnant
quoi tu peux dire ça comme ça et ça me
rend comme l'expression de soi même ses
expressions vraiment encore employé
quand tu vas tu peux le dire quoi faire
je te regarde comme les minerais d'un
amour joie ses parents que l'expression
écoute on essaye de s'amuser comme on
peut fabriquer moi je parie sur ces 4 tu
parais sur ces 4 way allez moi je vais
parier b4 je joue le coup des bourgeois
quoi il fut stylo qui veut que
soupçonnant émis le retweet et on gagne
par exemple on peut faire un truc 6000
euros 2,8 à soupçonner qu on peut offrir
une série vidéo sur le pion isaf l'écran
vidéo très sexy du cocon équivalence le
tout est dit qu'ils se faire recruter
son tweet oise oise à messi ja c'est toi
qui va la gagner à pas de chance
bon tu l'avais déjà il sera remis en jeu
une autre fois elle organise des trucs
que tu gagnes la récompense
ouais les quatre hommes bah c'est
l'autre partie avance acquise est pas là
l'autre demi finale celle entre ding
dirait mes fils evan oignons et digne
qui tente quand même quelque chose enfin
il veut être entreprenant dans cette
partie c'est il aurait pu faire le truc
avec fuji et cinq avaient l'air d'être
soumis insipide non il tend à drogba en
fait c'est bien sûr la période 4,5 dans
leur position si tu mets un point
faisant éclater bien mais bon
en tout cas je vous recommande pas de
faire ça chez vous de jouer avec h3g cap
dans cette position là bas au premier
coup pourquoi pas mais après c'est trop
tard
mais tu as tu géré les faut pas que les
joueurs amateurs se met à faire des
choses comme ça parce que ça c'est ya
souvent un retour de bâton à cause des
affaiblissements mais il veut jouer pour
le surnombre à la loi un peu comme on
l'avait vu dans les parties de gary
barlow j'aime attaquer un g3 angel
castro a balancé f4 et ses actes mais il
y avait une partie de dire et comme ça
contre somme je pense on l'avait fait
sur la chaîne quelque part il s'est
refait soit qu'il propose comme
expression je te regarde comme hanouna
regard d'un chiffre
je le regarde tati mais je pensais
vraiment intelligent il joue au con il
anime son truc mais ça veut dire ici a
tous su que ça c'est pas par hasard
qu'en fait ou alors évidemment très
chanceux même des gens qui ont beaucoup
de chance parfois donc bon écoute on
verra mais c'est intéressant ce que fait
ding c'est hier qu'on aura une partie de
rechange comme on va se concentrer sur
maxime parce que je pense qu'on peut
rapidement aller dans une direction dans
la partie de maxime qui ira soit vers la
nuls soit vers la nulle en fait
d'ailleurs x ou y mais bon on va pas
trop trop à souffrir mais je pense c'est
un coût important là que maxime a joué
ici j'ai importante ça va décider de ce
qui va faire nul facile et rapide ou
est-ce qui va un peu souffrir il est pas
venu ici pour souffrir votre look
et si j'ai juste un coup comme h3
admettons tu vois
tout dire au noir montre moi ce que tu
as dans le ventre pour progresser dans
cette position n'est mais saïd hamdine
gamsen oui vraiment il avait bien
mouillé mais il faut qu'il fasse quelque
chose
oui mais il va pas te faire grand chose
il va tous il va toucher un pion vers
son rôle a déjà évité des poèmes sur le
bfr est apte et ashes du coup c'est un
voyage en deux voilà à toi oui je te
fait roi dans les séries que ce n'est
pas le style de max nain bien plus non
plus au kef différents achats juste pour
voir est ce que des gens peut pas
commencer à être un peu chiant à faire
approuver apprend b assez pour faire à 4
et technique il y a trois qui vais la
tour dès que tu ne bouges pas ces deux
qui traîne et andré créé des petits
soucis quoi je sais pas alors attends
j'ai peut-être une autre idée du coup je
fais h 3 h 6 admettons que j'en ai quand
même et je fais tout re deux pour
poitiers bien ouais mais même en fait ok
ce que je vaux tentes jeudi à bab à 5 et
bien j'imagine il a créé vous bougez a
été mieux 4 et je sais pas ce que par la
piste autour c'est qu'à tours a gelé de
faire tourner tout est changé mes tours
c4 c'est chiant mais même pour un tour
en action mais en fait moi les noirs
sont pas sans idée donc avec les blancs
doit trouver un truc comme hockey après
je vais te faire à bcv ouais ouais ouais
ok si je te fais qualifié de cavalier ou
trois je pense que t'as plus rien après
rouge abuse
je sens que tu es chiffonné en fait je
suis chauvin et je serai pas à l'aise
quand je vois qu'on peut avoir une
position un peu un peu relou à jouer et
puis en plus tu sais que je compte
carlson et qui justement il est chiant
et pas simple mais du coup b4 est ce que
c'est si dieu non mais en plus ici une
suggestion de l'ordi c'est sur mon
maillot messin mais l'idée est tellement
clair en fait ces trois cas et c'est 2k
et de trois
tu te dis même les trois prochains coups
[Musique]
après puissance 4 tu es très mal quoi
l'a55 je voulais une faute mais du coup
h 5 à 8 ans je fais ces 3 way
alors est ce qu on intercale h4h troyes
aube à jans ouais on intercale bien
c'est une très bonne chose comme ça
s'organise et deux jours adam g 6 enfin
comme très attention à ce que tu dis
quoi bein je n'attends que je crois
aussi de pas mais j'ai le droit
et du coup les tatas 5 et waimes alors à
je sais pas ce qu'en fait non mais en
fait je suis sûr qu'on va mettre leur
div
il va nous défendre mais non mais on
comprend si sûr que leur dites aux
défenses à sans problème mais le truc
c'est que c'est ce que disait galles
fente dans son livre du machin
positionnelle dynamique là je peux
comment il s'appelle d'eric les devants
c'est le vert le rouge le rouge
positionnelle decision making lynch est
en fait il expliquait un truc soit
intéressant celui le plus dur aux échecs
ce quand tu as le choix entre trois
quatre nouvelles variantes qui en a une
ou en fête aura pas trop de problèmes à
la sortie il y en a trois autres où ça
va être dur à défendre mais dit c'est
hyper dur de choisir la variante qui
sera simple à défendre de trouver semble
pas ce que ça te des prix un peu quoi
c'est pas dans ton état d'esprit normal
quoi un peu déprimé te retrouver avec
les blancs preneur de sava plaisir quoi
non et pour kevin sans barbe dans le
chatt vlad il est très fier de son
anecdote donc tu perds tu peux en parler
en fait c'est pas un problème ça fait
qu'ils sont endormis sur l'échiquier
tout ça donc
en fait il a été le joueur d'échecs le
plus médiatisé en russie peut-être à ce
moment là bas donc forcément ce crime le
seul non ils ont parlé pendant cinq
minutes dans un talk show dans le plus
grand talk show sur la première chaîne
n'est pas le genre français super connu
c'est touzanne quoi bon il connut en 1/2
toujours connu qu'en fait ce qu'il a
battu à allende même étant départ est
partout que c'est à dire les journaux
les machins c'est incroyable elle a dix
ans et même parlé sur canal+ en france
avant c'est extraordinaire en fait
pincer sasebo d'en bas qui peut
s'asseoir à sa table
est-ce que je faire dame à 5 avec les
blancs enfin tu peux te mets dans mon
idée c'est que j'ai empêche la 5
ouais j'ai attaqué à quatre voix lui on
peut te laisser l'arrière mais peut-être
on peut prendre aussi même et je veux
peut-être dame c5 un jour au tours 7
tu vois je fais tu très énervé une
petite bombe à temps il a joué 1
il ajoute que ses carnets de juger par
là dessus mesdames à 5,6 is you je mets
un petit coup de rouge
moi je page 5 en fait comme ça on a
alors dit se dit qu il te dit à bab le
25 pour huit mois tout rond à béton
turin
[Musique]
vitalla mais franchement vous balance h
140 parce qu'on m'enlève les problèmes
de fond de ranger fin de match 5
bon courage 3 km on peut même variante
et c'était une option non mais j'ai fait
toute une option tout s'éclaire
mais pour abattre un truc assez clair
pour annuler quoi j'en aime bien mais ça
je trouve pas comme ça il a fait un bébé
à voir quoi
on avait pensé prise mais on a le temps
pour prendre je suis passé par 27 rue
qu'on regardait comme ça histoire se
poser des questions mais est-ce qu'on a
tellement envie d'un escalier à trois
ans et quatre cadeaux lui non tu as
raison c'est juste un truc qu'on a envie
de voir les stars se poser des questions
mais en fait quasi sûr qu'on a mieux à
faire avec les noirs que de prendre en
compte est du taux refi et agit quelque
chose
bon après tout rien appris des mots en
b3 donc logiquement quand tu joues en
coûte mp comme ça tu vas rejoint un truc
rapide derrière non normalement la
presse de son là d'être évidente que les
prendre enfin que le pion à quatre
effets sa vie et qu'il était temps de le
prendre quoi quoi qu'il en soit le coût
appartient à cette position je le joue
très vite
ouais et maintenant je réfléchis à fond
100% rassurer je suis pas méga inquiet
de la position j'ai pas dire on est
super mal ou quoi enfin ça dépend si
c'était contre un mec heures en dôme
j'aurais pas du tout peur mais la contre
magnus fait j'ai peur qu'on se retrouve
dans le genre de position que magnus
joue beaucoup mieux que maxime alors
après la position est légal et ça doit
aller mais je comprends un peu ton
inquiétudes mais c'est chez passe en
fait c'est pas nul où on prêt sous 20
même fait semblant de presser et l'autre
va être précis de coûts ont fait nul
semaine à des blancs et c'est à nous
d'être prêts six mois et c'est chiant ça
peut être pénible pendant une petite
dizaine de coups ou très longtemps
tiendront dans une finale contre
cavaliers je sais pas quoi
ouais bah dit que ce soit si court qua
non c'est un peu mais bon après hier
c'est maxime qui dominait avec les noirs
n'ont plus tôt et mais il arrive
toujours position qu'il faut là où c'est
le bordel mais l'ambition sous marque
opposé ok tu attaques le roi c'est
compliqué il est dans son élément
là ça ressemble moins ça il a falsifié
stocker juste un coup mais c'est ce dont
tu parlais à essayer les ford pourra
rester sur place
non c'est qu'il faut trouver les jeux je
suis pas sûr qu'on va sécher la position
comme ça en fait c'est ça le problème
mais lou gehrig après décès déception a
fait peur lors il peut faire un peu peur
après tu le bloc de loin mais oui mais
je pense que l'idée c'est de prendre
avec le cavalier à trois ans et quatre
pour faire les sales puants passé
papillon basse et tu laisses pas ton
cavaliers complètement en dehors du jeu
sinon ça ressemblerait trop à la partie
malgré tout juste par guy ritchie
campbell non mais du coup si tu veux at
il donc avais tu peux toujours prendre
des cinq faire crisser 4 à ce moment là
mais sûrement que c'est un truc qui va
essayer de faire maxime pour au moins un
peu hâtive et tu auras et tour 5 et
dames c3 fait un truc comme ça tu passes
un peu pas mal tes pièces mais il faudra
faire gaffe à b3 il faudra faire gaffe à
la tour carrée mambé 8 non c'est un peu
pénible mais fait un peu gaffe je suis
d'accord creuseurs sa voix la voix sait
pas où après ok c'est lui le probable
même faire un peu gaffe
alors après ce que le temps ça peut être
un problème dans ses positions la rue
norvins comme ça après m'enfin faut
quand même faire gaffe de paresser tu
avec 15 minutes dans une finale deux
tours un peu bizarre quoi me ces deux
heures chaos ces deux heures 10 k o
d'accord donc tu vas pas récupéré de
temps enfin fo disons que je suis pas du
tout inquiète autant à la pendule pour
le moment mais bon si pas si tu te
retrouves avec 20 minutes que ça
commence à être un peu tu vois il faut
être très précis et où t'as jamais 30
secondes en fait non c'est du délai en
plus tu peux pas remonté à 1
il reste plus de deux heures à magnus
web
ils avaient deux heures 10 au début il a
été employé que cinq minutes bon il n'a
pas trop eu à jouer le coup pour
l'instant faute donc et je te fais juste
une mini pause basile bonne minute mais
je fais la mini pause du coup si adam le
chargé des questions n'hésitez pas à
rebondir position n'est pas évidente
pour pour mike slim qui donc comme on le
disait avec fab position
et on va pas dire moins bien qui est
plus dur à jouer on va être précis qui
est plus difficile à jouer pour les
blancs où il ya plus de possibilités
d'erreurs après c'est sûr que si on la
passe sur un ordi très fort elle va
donner 000 puisqu'elle doit être
fondamentalement nul mais ça demande une
précision plus importante côté blanc
parce que il ya du jeu sur deux elle
donc on voit qu'il ya des pions des deux
côtés de l'échiquier sur les deux ailes
et que le fou on si on imagine survenir
sur des 5 par exemple après quelques
échanges juste on va on va se l'imaginer
je vais le mettre au dessus bref pas le
mettre au dessus de l'armoire on va
jouer on va remettre à laon mamadou est
exprimé ci on imagine en dessin que ce
fou il apte à créer et à l'oeil droit et
à l'ale dames alors que le cavalier lui
c'est une pièce courte portée et ils
auraient plus de mal alors évidemment on
peut le mettre en deux trois ou à cinq
il peut faire un boulot suffisant pour
équilibrer le fouet pas trop derrière
mais faut faire attention du succès sont
les noirs qui ont les plans qui
permettrait de prendre l'aventage alors
que les blancs eux sont légères
souffrance en souffrance ou net j'ai
envie de dire est ce que je peux dire
souffrance ou net
elles sont là le droit de dire ce mot
est ce que c'est un mot autorisée sur
sur ce live du type petite souffrance ou
dette côté blanc donc bon maxime qui
doit être précis là on voit le kw/h 6
qui en a joué par magnus
il prend pas l'initiative du jeu il s il
s maxime un petit peu
un peu comme un boxeur qui tape un peu
dans le vide j'ai envie de dire il s il
s à maxime les choix à faire donc pas
évident par exemple on voit qu'on peut
pas s'activer avec un tour sept jours et
j'imagine du dam des six qui fait une
double attaque
donc ça on peut pas être un coup comme
damas un qu'on avait imaginé tout à
l'heure et jouable ici peut-être qui
avec l'idée de mettre une attaque
latéral sur le fou et sans prendre un
peu à tous les pointages juste vous
aussi ce blinde et s'en prend pions c4
et si on prend le sait le fou qui
reprend et là on est tout à fait dans le
cas de figure dont je vous parlais tout
à l'heure avec le fouet la dame qui
jouerait bien qu'ils attaqueraient de
pions b3 qui attaqueraient g2 donc ma
foi
pas évident je le retour tu es de retour
et non je disais tu ailles à damas cinq
à serait pas terrible a cette fois eu
six tours s'inquiètent d'être fou ici
c'est aussi et tu as dès que tu prends
ce que je montrais c'est que le fouillis
c'est ça la force ne le faudrait faire
un jeu des deux côtés on s'affaiblit
pareille date s'éprend d'elle donc le
flou viennent en façade à maintenir
dessus tu es trop qu'ayant c4 à son tu
défends b3 tu menaces enfin c'est un
autre immature ou 5 mais tu vas mettre
quoi la dame en c3 sûrement ça une tête
de truc peut être bon quoi après faut
regarder tourner 8 aussi ok peut-être
cavaliers ou trois ici mes gars comme
toi ou cinq ans mais en deçà bahia non
mais le matin
ouais je vais te bats je peux montrer au
moins ça fait une petite variante mais
tu peux juste faire qu'à radio 3
j'imagine dame 17 vous pouvez vous
résumer c'est juste pour montrer voilà
ça ce serait bien pour les blancs en
fait ce serait nul tout de suite il ya
deux faiblesses de chaque côté il ya pas
assez de matériel
d'ailleurs je sens un truc pas mal je
sais pas si vous en dvd mais bon c'est
pas prenne pas avec le pistolet que
c'est mieux dompter la défense passive
quand c'est un pion c'est que le pion à
eux comme structure gérée par les eaux
et de la française plutôt que l'option
désolé de tout les numéros des machins
là ce qui en fait quand tu joues pour
regagner le pion avec le clouage avec
les pièces lourdes soit colonne des tu
veux faire 5 en général amel et blanc ce
qu'ils font et fiat du coup de chauffe
et de la faune et là tu peux faire juste
b 4 way et c'est beaucoup moins
compromettant en fait on n'a pas parlé
mais il faudra faire une deuxième
édition
je dois être là devenons il très con ça
ne veut rien dire ce qu'il veut vraiment
pas que tu viens de voir qu'à vlad à la
can en fait j'ai compris c'est en fait
tu vas devoir dire deux trois trucs
intelligents comme ça et puis après tout
d'un coup il va y penser quoi incroyable
et grand maître quoi imagine cinquième
fois
comment il peut dire pas avec un
revêtement du court est tu veux plus
facilement essayer de défendre passifs
sont à ce cas de figure que l'ogc nice
qui se ferme et quatre pour hockey
dublin de quoi enfin je viens là c'est
pas tellement la position ça serait plus
un genre d'un pion à 2 les normes durant
bessette comme ça tu as d'ailleurs il a
pris en d5
bon je pense à me risquer à autre chose
que dame prend des 5
pas vraiment enfin se sont tu vas ou
quoi kessé capte sans que tu te
reprendre ses pions ces panneaux lui et
ses amis que je me pose des questions
non tu as raison d'un nombre de motos
questionner quoi ouais bon ça fait
prendre peut-être une bonne habitude
dans le chat de toujours la page ou
tempo
non en fait je pensais à quoi parce
qu'en fait je pense à quelque chose
comme c'est de faire d'alger 6 ça va pas
marcher mais avec l'idée et fable a tout
de suite compris se faire flouer quatre
menaces et mat c'est de reprendre quand
même avec le fou mais il imagine tu fais
juste un truc comme ça me 3 ici tu
empêches fougue cas tu protèges h3 et ça
sert à rien donc ça me prend des 5 oui
c'est sûr et qui a réalisé 4 c'est sûr
je pense on a fait tout ça pour ça pour
recycler ce cavalier qui était très mal
placé 1 à 3 et au passage on défend nos
pions nos petits pions de 3 way je pense
que ça allait quand même femme non mais
je crois aussi mais maxime qui aura
enfin souffert non c'est pas le move
c'est pas le mot mais il aura pas il a
bien joué quoi il prend bien son temps
et il en arrive justement pas au point
de souffrir en fait oui mais
c'est clairement pas la partie dont il
rêvait quoi sans lui dire il souffre pas
pro par prophylaxie quoi non plus près
il ya plein de sérieux qu'on veut pas
voir contre spart1e au sénat voudrait on
dit quand même ville auraient besoin de
recycler le car elle irait à poubelles
jaunes quoi ce qu'ils essaient 4 quoi
qu'ils veulent jouer notre jeu c'est sur
ce registre est génial qu'il insiste non
c'est mon cavalier lecavalier mvl je ne
toucherai pas ouais mon trade mark
knight quoi serait bouabré tu fais un
dvd sur lesquels il y en a trois très
fort qui montre que des parties des vie
vous les mecs ont gagné quoi quand je
vois du coup tu recommandes à fond aux
quatre ses seins plâtre ouais même pas
si les bilans fait que 4 c 5 avaler à 3
c'est pas mal qu'il développe
tu vois si tu fais une sorte de lapine
sorte de rosso limo fin tu garde toutes
les options cas très intéressant mais tu
gardes car ya je crois aussi ronsard l
autre côté comment ça se passe au mieux
le g4 il est parti manger 6 logique a eu
deux cas ici six ont été lents à croître
et il a fait tout resserre bonjour je
leur dis pas très fun ouais mais l'ordi
est pas très fort et j'ai peur qu'ils
donnent bunak malus à ce truc là non
peut-être
non mais oh qu'il a raison aussi de
gourdes non il ya cet ordinateur ne
comprends absolument à cette position
incroyable
non mais le truc c'est que si tu
justifies pas un peu ton attaque pendant
moins dynamique où cos est un peu
bizarre mais bon après ça va parce que
brooke face comme les joueurs sauvier ce
n'est pas du genre politique mais joue
un russe ou même français ou repères à
l'époque voter pour le journal dingli
rennes qui a besoin de ce but mais c'est
tellement beau cet été au courant de ce
truc là ou pas non plus tout juste pour
ceux qui n'étaient pas là
pl ne me raconte ce matin parce qu'il a
fait plein de recherches historiques sur
les échecs au 19e siècle
et il m'expliquait que si les joueurs
jouent de manière romantique dont il
était déjà influencé par leur époque
l'époque romantique
d'un point de vue général dans tout
l'est dans tous les domaines mais aussi
parce que comme il n'y avait pas
vraiment de prix dans les tournois
d'échecs où il était assez assez petit
il avait des mécènes bon ça c'est une
première chose mais il avait aussi
parfois des revues qui publiait avec
leur meilleure partie tournois et donc
c'était mieux d'avoir envoyé fin c'est
vrai que là la partie mvl magnus bon bah
en fait tu n'as plus aucun donc coiffer
un des gages à l'est déjà je pense qu'il
n'aurait pas du tout respecté
enfin tu fais b3 rock je pense que à
l'époque tu es obligé de fermer prend
1,4 en fait c'est un minimum de respect
pour la personne non mais en fait à
l'époque c'est bien qu'ils acceptaient
tous les sacrifices
elle est bien je veux c'est bon ça que
c'était un truc philosophique ou un peu
on te jette un grand tu dois accepter
pour ton honneur je savais pas qu'ils
avaient signés non mais il ya ce truc
non mais il expliqué ce truc là aussi un
blad que c'était l'époque romantique et
donc c'était normal de vouloir laisser
faire à l'autre une belle partie mais en
fait pas que ce qu'il fallait aussi
montré des belles parties aux gens c'est
un art ou quoi donc
tiens au fait tu sais tu veux quasiment
en équipe avec ton adversaire en quelque
sorte quoi pas assez beau en fait de
penser les échecs comme ça comme un art
ouais bah en fait c'est un peu un
mélange majeur c'est d'ailleurs façon on
dit ça me l'enjeu sports sciences arts
et chacun peut se reconnaître plus dans
une branche des trois quoi ouais après
bon bah moi pour le coup je suis plus
dans le côté compétition mais aussi
j'aime bien le côté esthétique en tant
qu'amateur tu veux que je te montre en
exclu qu'un appareil est vraiment pourri
à la partie qui a montré aujourd'hui que
de petrov je la monte pas rapide un jeu
la montre juste comme ça on l'analysera
peut-être un autre jour où quoi il
s'agit tu la copie colle ouais je la
copie comme les y attend je lâche
propose un bide ça des mecs non je songe
copie colle à la peau copie colle ici
donc on va dire le contraire c'est
génial comme l'admet on voit la partie
écrite journaux
voilà il ne sais pas si je jouais contre
des journaux si c'était publiés dans des
journaux ou s'ils jouaient contre un mec
qui s'appelait journaux quoi c'est
extraordinaire t'as rien n'a pas pu
trouver ce que c'est une vieille partie
on ne pouvait pas être possible ce soit
un peu les partis majoritaires à
l'époque
où les gens de ré une lettre au journal
est assez possible mais du coup il y
aurait écrit journal pourquoi journaux
on n'a pas réussi à savoir en fait mais
du coup il n'y a pas de faim voilà mais
regarde la partie ok donc que trop fade
et blanc retrouveront donc la passe est
juste une question de voici quelques
années peut être 1850 par là il est né
en 17 99
donc du coup bon ça c'était la vente
très à la mode déjà hockey des jo est
non greffe ou bessin ou machin annoncé
il ya déjà des zéros déjà de la wla de
m'expliquer en fait ne pas jouer kg 3
ici c'est une honte en fait pour les
noirs à l'époque voyez une belle case tu
va attaquer à tour fait tu es obligé en
fait de faire kg 3 non mais vraiment il
veut dire en fait se fait pas piéger 3 c
c'est un manque de respect quoi il fait
cavalier g3 menace la tour est bon là tu
peux faire tous rachetés ou tour j'en ai
monté pleut non sûrement pas quatre mois
ont été obligés de faire qui froisse ça
va pour l'ate est vraiment obligé
vidarte à toute façon on n'a pas le
choix en fait madame roig 4 tu as quand
même pas le choix non plus quoi
d'anormal dégâts je te donne encore un
tube à la t2 nouveau obligé de prendre c
est compliqué qu adam eve deux cavaliers
f5
du coup d'un match 4 h 6 e recettes non
on va bouger les cinq échecs en fait
c'est chaud m6 vous prend h4 ouais mais
peut-être été plus en sécurité
tapez de cazaux tortora que coincé en g8
n'ont en fait trois gîtes pas vraiment
une faute c'est en fait c'est ok vas-y
bouge et moi la partie fret ferroviaire
roi des deux tours 1 et on a un peu
analysé c'est très chaud en fait comme
position où je me fais fou h 6,3 g 8
mais regarde elle va le niveau quoi j'ai
passé dix huit cents et quelques et tu
voir la position finale est vraiment my
man
merci aux déviations du coup les
journaux se battent à fond mais tu vois
là la position finale va être
extraordinaire bataille autour de moi
mais en fait tu as tout bloquer la basse
avec l'avancée de w9
ouais c'est ça mais en fait c'est
fantastique j'ai dit ouais le début je
me souvenais pas mais maintenant je vois
ça je comprends mais oui si on vous à
voir venir toi la position finale
extraordinaire mais c'est nul mais je
la position à la fin c'est d'une beauté
incroyable non nommé deux potes petrov
qui est à fond ce côté esthétique du
jury ouais mais la partie est magnifique
en soi mais j'aime bien en fait
conseiller sur un blog il explique tout
ça très bien je pense fait dix minutes
sur la partie vous êtes oui mon là tu
manques de respect ou quoi mais mais
mais je trouve ça tellement beau à la
fin le roi qui bloque le pion le fou qui
bloque le pô le pion de l'autre côté
enfin ça s'équilibre mais doit-on fois
j'écris un aspect le roi et la tour
enfin les mecs ne rigolait pas à
l'époque
et donc ça oui c'était on pense que
c'était publiés dans des journaux et
donc les mecs en fait pour voir des
partis comme ça filer du fric
donc c'est pour ça qu'en fait 20 une
partie mvl magnus comme on voit
maintenant en fait à l'époque 0 bah oui
même tueur dit oui payement ma place je
suis pas venu pour voir ça mais c'est ça
c'est ça mais j'ai je ne pensais pas
peut-être ça va s'animer d'ailleurs mais
pour l'instant le public debout près le
après l'ouverture quoi sa marque le pas
mais du coup ma faim avec la bomba un
parallèle on disait qu'en réalité les
streamer fait le phénomène des streamer
qui arrivait sur les échecs partir de
2015 on va dire qu'il ya commencé un an
en 2015
le stand d'accueil 200 ans en fait c'est
comme la mode dans les vêtements ça va
ça vient et tout ça est en fait tu vois
que les streamer les plus populaires
entre guillemets même les bras ou quoi
c'est parce que il envoie et qui font un
peu le beau jeu et du coup c'est les
échecs en fait ils retournent à leur
essence quelque part avec sa note dans
le sens où ces deux nouveaux les gens
ont plus envie de voir des belles
parties que des parties parfaites
insipide voilà enfin juste c'est les
discussions de ce matin non mais tu ne
sens pas la partie très joli voile a
cédé au milieu de cette discussion monde
mais voilà ta tablette à ces discussions
qui s'arrête et oui c'est là où tu
arrêter un marrant comme mon mur tu as
high cube
je sais pas comment il en est venu à
faire ce lien mirta ses dettes il a vu
de mardi de petrov qantas connaît rien
petrov julien peut-être que petrov en
1858 déjà mieux que mur tu as
aujourd'hui françois tatti toi tu es fou
mais ouais t'as saimone williams souci
qui envoie un peu et qui fait plaisir
etc
c'est un peu le retour à cette essence
la du des échecs du 19e siècle en fait
ça donne complètement hui tout le temps
en fait quand tu joues en tournois ni il
envoie ses petits l'embellie ception h
mais c'est beau et ça qui lui plaît dans
le jeu bon après évidemment c'est moins
efficace
malheureusement pas en fait c'est moins
efficace aussi parce que tu as plus ce
truc d'avant de tu me manques de respect
qua non je ne te prend fin je te prends
une pièce ou deux après seront pas les
autres mais je t'échange tout je
télécharge ou un gars de ma finale web
pragmatisme enfin mon pragmatisme époque
tu fais ça bravo qu'enfin palmarès j'ai
récolté 0 euros les gens me détestent
c'est génial quand mon journal fait zéro
vente personne ne publier enfin plus
personne de jouer contre toi là je crois
que c'était de le devenir du hammer
magazine c'est beau quand tu avais plus
d'adversaires en fait ils s'en foutent
est parti je suis le meilleur du monde
et dégage en fait on ne veut pas devoir
du commun bus qui a fait au 6 août ils
se placent un peu face à b3 et peut-être
en blessa d'admettre le fond des cinq
comme tu disais avant du cours dillon
logique on va voir comment maxime se
débrouille pour pourchasser ci peut
mettre le cas vaillant de trois ans
souvent le pion ça ira mais il fait
tourner 05 très logique je pensais pas
on a plus ou moins paraître placement
grande classe pour peut-être plus à
verser 5 un peu attaqué ses sets tu
tiens le pion à à distance 11 ans est
très dur pour les gens d'affaires à 5,8
en fait me faisais à 5 à 4 c'est un peu
chiant qu'ils enlèvent le socle aux
cavaliers et ça crée un problème déclaré
lecavalier tape détroit faible si c'est
bien de l'empêcher battu puis par voix
réclament aujourd'hui 17 blessés mais on
peut pas jouer le retour c'est ce
pourquoi pas je viens tu laisses la case
au cavalli peut-être way est d'amasser 3
sort des 8e mais ton
je vais refaire un peu l'accès des
échanges massif
on perd des 4 ans et 7 j'ai même tour
des 3 enfin hockey même sa rage et tour
à satee basta enfin où on échange à bord
le foutou recettes chuter le sens bon là
d'ailleurs c'est encore mieux comme ça
vu que l'on rit aussi mais bon même ça
faut souligner que c'est juste une
phrase est ce à quoi je pensais en
veut-on elle est facile ou pas relative
et maxime finul à son problème
nous lui disions non me connaît bien
évidemment il est bien fini ouais ouais
donc gamme 17 ours et 5
on craint vraiment rien non bah j'aime
bien fait je sais pas moi qui ai un truc
qui m'échappe mais j'aime bien pour
faire dame c3 pour faire d'un efi quatre
heures d'un match peu importe mais un
truc on va s'activer enfin on fera un
petit siège 3 et et je pense se doit les
tubes ou plus enthousiastes entre
guillemets de cette position que celle
qu'on a vraiment faim en gros je ne sais
pas j'étais jamais et qui à 1000% mais
je voyais à des scénarios ça tournait
mal
mais là pour le coup là et tu peux dire
scénario en fait j'ai vérifié
là ça se dit aussi ben en fait ça s'est
vraiment scénario fait scénarii pas se
dit pas du tout en fait non on y passe
non pas en raison du scénario et enfin
les mots étrangers tu habites le
francine moi je suis à fond tu as aimé
mais j'étais sûr rester une faute et
qu'on faisait tous ça c'est qu'en fait
la 60e seul coup c'est moi qui ai
festivités commencent à se faire faire
la faute de dire c'est pareil percée
pour longtemps comme un tempo de tempi
quoi tu vas mais ça aussi ça soit en idf
des tempos d'été mais pourtant ce thème
qui normalement bah oui tu francis le
pluriel en fait c'est comme en fait on
dirait panino normalement ouais mais
alors là dessus je suis française le
singulier mais bon on va pas de chance
bref madame b ça peut-être que je me
suis alors dit tu dises faire jusqu'à
vallée à 5 et le plus logique
mb 6 am c3 et était en place tu as en
place et orbi lancé cinq passes et le
premier quotidien l'esprit du coup ça va
de tatous bien bloquer tout un bric à 38
ans et je pense ouais ouais c'est
miellat telle à quoi tu es en place mais
toujours en place de la banque propose
nuls la voile et la fée d'am-dam 17
donc on disait quoi on a fêté ses cinq
tours dès 8 h 3 et tout est changé où on
est seul truc
ok peu d'autres combattants concernant
la zac allée à 5 non ma fille tu as un
quite vous prendre les trois m'ont dit
on échange un même toit ça dans mes
textes encore mieux et l'ordi de dif ou
des cinq tours prend 1,6 et toujours à
trois arrêts ok alors mon mari mon
épouse en retour à ça tu peux faire vous
aussi c'est peut-être qu'elle et ses 6
ils échangent fou de sa taille se fait
tour à 4 voilà encore me céder 6 du coût
pour des clous et il ya fou prend ses
six vent et on va dire une partie à
l'est qui ne veulent comme ça en fait où
le plant je donnerai qu'un tour à 4
c'est beau il ya un lobby très
facilement mais pour le coup j'ai oublié
d'accord non mais du coup je joue la
finale de thouars à cape town - sinon si
on fait ça oui celle qu'on a vue h 4
bien il a faim les pharmaciens
j'avais vu que c'est le coût que
l'audition s'était très ordinateur est
ce qu'un tour des huit à borg et mon
beauf bouffe bouffe au stade dommage de
skema du couloir 1 toujours belle bon ok
on va le lâcher
j'aimerais enfin je sais pas vous
bouffez ça tu peux signer un tour des
six tours 6
bon ok sûrement le sérieux qu'on va voir
tu vois des gens jan aps le singulier
pour plusieurs problèmes
maija ils essayent en vain qui t'a dit
le conseil supérieur langue française en
97 des déconseillé l'usagé dans les
documents officiels de la république
française est une thune italiani ce pas
le lui dis je veux dire un lit beezup
sco quoi ça serait beau mais en fait
pour ça que ça va un côté latin et que
tu dois respecter dans un sit-in du truc
je sais pas ben ali ne respecte rien en
gros bon du coup les journaux sont très
mécontents il donne aucun type i aux
joueurs pour cette partie ouais voilà
dakar ça ok quand même descendu à venir
cinquantaine je pensais qu'ils étaient
encore au dessus des 2 heures il aurait
pu dire je suis pas sûr qu'en bility
large à d'autres coups c'est bon ses
stylistes aura 3 pouces bouffe tour
derrière le pion tabasse non mais c'est
à des choix et ne plus de l'agglo 6 pour
montréal
ouais c'est cool ils gagnent des points
elo après par rapport aux tournois qui
se profile à jérusalem c'est quand même
très anecdotique quoi mais bon c'est
plutôt rassurant sur sa forme ça c'est
la bonne nouvelle
il a fait un nul comme à nantes c'est
bien et ce qui comptait sur moi comme tu
le dis si j'ose à l'âme mais déjà demain
il peut il peut se qualifier
ben je le vois pas très loin de cape
town pour ce match en rapide et beat
c'est tout ce qu'on lui souhaite un tout
le mal qu'on lui souhaite de toute façon
qu'ils gagnent ou qu'ils perdent ils
obligés de rester à londres donc j'ai
envie de dire autant qu'il y ait match
pour la troisième place
un match pas trop là tu en fis de partir
ben non pas de chance tu vas devoir
rester non même si tu as des problèmes
respiratoires ou quoi non mais sur la
troisième place c'est le pompon non mais
certaines cayfo candidat vous quoi pas
sur les trottoirs et du coup ses parents
qui va gagner moi qui ai une bonne
raison de rester claque fils 3e 4e du
grand czestochowa pour le coup vraiment
fait quand même y avoir un droit de voir
de différence aux adultes interdit ou
qu'est ce qu'il ya c'est pourquoi ça
continue joseph s'ils ont envie de
continuer on in gerusalemme ça commence
mardi non ça colosse réponse le 11 jeux
mercredi alors du 11 au 23
je vais les sucs et vite fait comment
empêcher le pion à six deux dames et ben
en fait si tu veux le dire mais tu as
fait retour à la raison que je fasse ça
tu vas faire ça je fais ça tu fais ça je
fais ça tu fais ça je fais ça tu fais ça
et je fais ça par exemple est en fait
comment est-ce que tu va avancer le pion
obligé la tour et du coup de cube au
château on encaisse le pion est alors un
truc à ne jamais trahir du coup c'est ne
jamais jouer roger trouve un autre
hongrois soit 3 m
on se prend un échec et le pion arrive
et ne jamais quitter les cases j'ai 2 h
2 parce que si tu feras f2 ya to russia
ils menacent dame tu prends un tu te
fais contourner tu perds ta tour voilà
c'est juste les règles à savoir pour ne
pas perdre comme ça mais du coup si tu
fais rien qui fait que roy g 2o h deux
timbres j'aimerais et si le roi
s'approche de toi responsable michel
j'ai quand même montré mais du coup on
fait mal c'est pas les pions h et tous
ses pions blancs seraient nuls quand
même un pion f pour la mare pour gagner
pour te dévier le roi il a du coup de
hache de g24 entier y protège champions
qui est très heureux tu fais échec mais
tu comptes faire venir des gens là 8 ou
faire des échecs en fait conclut dès
qu'ils touchent allusion à deux et les
noirs sont toujours couverts de même
problème en boucle est impossible de
faire quelque chose superbe rumeurs
démenties un tirage au sort pour le
grand prix n'ont pas encore ça sera fait
la veille
donc je pense qu'on saura mardi ouais
après vingt mille dollars et tu as même
maxime quand il parlait du match pour la
3ème place de la coupe du monde dit que
c'était anecdotique ce qui avait que 10
dollars en jeu donc en fait à ce niveau
là pour eux pour leurs réalités faut
comprendre que 10000 20000 dollars c'est
fin c'est rien en fait ils craignent
vraiment bien leur vie les joueurs de
hull grand plus là tu as vraiment plus
important à faire
oui mais gérant général paraît c'est pas
du tout une critique c'est bien
l'inversé et pour dire c'est bien que
les joueurs d'échecs gagnent bien leur
vie et on est les premiers à être
heureux du coup on fait partie de ce
monde donc c'est bien pour tout le monde
mais je veux dire les joueurs de haut
niveau sont vraiment pas des gens qui
sont dans le besoin ils gagnent vraiment
des grosses sommes tout au long de
l'année sur le circuit ils ont dit on a
quasiment toutes les semaines
donc pour eux 10000 20000 dollars s'est
passé rien fait vraiment pas de socke et
sylvain une fois c'est rien après ces
jours ci devait cracher dessus tout les
deux semaines second sera quelque chose
oui mais on s'est compris jacques que
oui une fois dans l'année c'est pas
grave ben je pense que le dernier suisse
finit 4e façon il prend déjà cinquante
mille donc je pense à l'immense d'autres
entre 50000 et 70000 donc quand on gagne
c'est champions bah écoute plusieurs
dans le top10 plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'euros par an oui ce qui est
beaucoup et peu à la fois en réalité toi
tu gagnes le championnat du monde de
forte taille tu prends 3 millions mais
c'est sur le store de public quoi oui on
va dire que comparer je suis d'accord
avec toi comparé au public que ça
apporte et tous à ceux qui gagnent c'est
impressionnant c'est énormément d'argent
c'est peut-être même la discipline la
mieux payée au monde
si tu mets en relation avec le public
enfin j'en suis même sûr une des mieux
payés au monde mais bon c'est pas non
plus énorme
non mais que je vais pour le lis porte
en fait ça va ça devient tellement
populaire ça va je crois pas que ça a
dépassé le foot mais ce sera peut-être
le deuxième sport le plus je suis enfin
le au monde c'est pas encore le cas
[Musique]
ouais après tu as encore le golf la
formule 1 le goff nous garde en disant
ça je veux dire mais ça va monter ça va
être face ça dépasse déjà les échecs ça
c'est sûr c'est énorme quand tu vois les
salles publiques août ont déchaîné
ce que ça ramène comme monde est gentil
sur internet c'est incroyable après
après c'est de l'argent privé sedif
complètement différent des échecs ou
face et de l'argent de sociétés de c'est
du marketing c'est des investissements
marketing des échecs c'est juste du
mécénat ou des impôts qui payent mais
pour le coup de joan laporta et war 3 2
ms que les échecs sont feinte
irrégulière c'est mais en fait je peux
comprendre qu'il ya de tels prix à forza
est au coeur parce qu'il ya tellement de
monde qui regarde mais c'est très
populaire à la baule annuler un roi
contre roy quand même non mais ça c'est
un beau débat mais dont mai mais bon
c'est positif que qui est de l'argent
dans les échecs et que les joueurs de
qualité talents comme maxime magnus etc
puisse puisse bien gagner leur vie quoi
mais faut juste comprendre que valait 20
mille dollars de différence quant à
cantat comme disait fable est candidat
au bout de trois jours après c'est le
rêve d'une carrière c'est le rêve d'une
vie
mais sur blue quoi tous les oblige à
faire sans comprendre sans faute qui
finit troisième
mais pour de vrai en fait ok encore de
nature et que gagner ça qualifie pour
rien on l'a déjà dit bon c'est comme ça
mais encore ok peut-être que pour le
titre tu voir ses joueurs à rester parce
que le match c'est important toujours la
saison là-dessus mais qui finissent
troisièmes quatrièmes là vraiment c'est
anecdotique
panahi d'offres et joueurs faire ça
avant un truc qui tout sauf anecdotique
je trouve même pas sa classe de la part
de l'organisateur et même dans beaucoup
de compétition ça commence à être ccsa
de moins en moins lieu c'est match pour
la troisième place
regarde l'euro par exemple de foot ça
existe de foot de rugby mais encore
souvent tue mais l'équipe b en fait tu
es salam et c'est par dessus la jambe
en fait j'étais sur place et puis t'as
pas ton championnat sur marco rubio non
mais je pense que c'est plus sain le
match pour la troisième place au foot au
rugby là comme on en parle c'est plus de
l'exhibition j'entends verrez une grotte
en fait ce serait plus ça en fait au
foot ou au rugby look et est pas une
robe ce que tu as vu ce pas mais tu
joues des ventes un peu marrant tout
sans voix et mais c'est entre ces plus
de l'exhibition d'ailleurs là pour la
peine au foot ou au rugby
bon bah du coup quel sens peut lire
cette partie attention a dit enfin
attention pour ding chun bien c'est plus
ça lui est cher
après on va pas avoir mal à suivre je
pense simplement donner un petit peu
restait quand même enfin je dois passer
c'est pas dingue mais mais bon on peut
c'est pas drôle c'est qu'on a un peu de
la première page du machin du truc tu
vois j'ai un peu regardé tu vois
pourquoi pas sur un petit mois fin je ne
peux de ding ding dong
enfin pourquoi pas quoi bordel j'ai le
droit j'ai le droit de suivre digne
bordel bon jusqu'à 19h en bon bah je
sais pas je ne mets pas la pression
les gens décident on et 3500 sur ce live
via dean qui joue j'ai envie de te dire
j'ai envie de faire du digne quoi les
quelque 3500 fin ce matin quand même
3500 personnes qui sont là qui te
regarde et qui se disent que veut partir
est ce que vous voulez jouer en bullet
phadia y comprennent pas qu enfin ils se
disent peut-être qu'en fait enfin c'est
pas ce qu'on fait en fait froid on ne la
regardez le candidat féminin si on a les
parties aussi tu vas voir un peu de
katia l'agglo fâché mais on peut se
faire plaisir en fait je propose qu'on
s'amuse qu'on soit tu en mode freestyle
en mode
viens on se fait plaise en fait bien on
fait ce qu'on veut en fait on se force
pas de regarder ça on regarde un peu les
fidjiens on ne fait jamais un peu de
grand prix à monaco c'est pas loin y
avant à bahia que des nuls mais of the
party il ya vanina alors on peut
regarder vanina du coup c'est une copine
c'est donc nous on croque cheville
fait intéressant comme partie en plus
c'est une vraie espagnol ouvert trop le
jeu des sponsors je compte conejo donc
alors les mauvais non
tant pis a dormi j'ai mauvais non mais
alors attends je vais bien faire les
choses et bien je maigris nina li nina
conejo attend koné ou wlan il en a très
peur il m'a dit très forte m la lutte
des bons résultats je prends récemment
mais non il m'a dit très dangereuse donc
falloir cette pollution
on peut on repasse la partie vite fait
donc là pour le coup c'est une promesse
post c'est une vraie vente ouverte deux
espagnols donc ça peut nous intéresser
vu que l'on en a parlé de personnes
maximum donc là il ya eu foule 7
il ya eu l'avant 2 classique avec des
cinq fours b3 dookie attaquer et des
cinq dons qui stabilise la situation
centre on prend un malin prix du cavaly
d'avion production mais alors attention
elles sont très bien préparés non mais
ça mais en fait je connais même pas
qu'ils vont vous laddh me dit un niveau
de préparation similaire à 2720 1750
non mais les cessions mais très longs
débats l'entraînement décès ça rigole
pas quoi oui mais le niveau de
préparation
impressions bon du coup j'ai
l'impression que vanina était bien et il
permet un oui mais là c'est super tu
voir un tel flou à temps ouais un peu
laissé échapper ma laisse échapper à ses
shows à lait bouillant de cette partie
ces belles parties qua non en fait à
jouer aux échecs à l'ancienne quelque
part il nous apporte aux deux parties
comment là on fait le tipi pour cette
partie oui voilà tu en voilà peut-être
pas trois fois elle enlève la tour est
donc oui qui demande maxime a fait nul
tout se jouera demain dans la partie
rapide et blitz position là c'est
passionnant mais j'aime bien les blancs
bon après c'est à voir parce que c'est
vrai que les noirs peuvent prendre
angers 5 quand même là pour moi il ya
tourcoing f cet échec non oui mais
lequel il peut prendre tu prends du
charme à l'étude fait pas sur dieu tu
cours avec toi enfin à temps elles sont
super mal autant en plus c'est dans ce à
quoi la cadence
ça je ne sais pas ça se trouve l on sait
vraiment pas de chance quoi on arrive
juste au moment où s'arrête la pause
d'une demi heure ouais mais ça va
envoyer et l'autre partie qui reste coi
avoir aidé nul partout où des signes
cram unis voilà c'est nul
non c'est la seule partie intéressante
car ce style even non contre ok on a
deux d'autres des trucs à regarder pas
de partis sympa quoi dameuse d'amd 8 tu
fais quoi
qu'est ce qui te tenterait lac léman
bon ben maintenant deux des huit années
reprend donc le f-18 et non donner de
noms mais en fait on n'a pas de quoi
renforcer l'attaqué mais en fait je vais
faire un truc de fouine mais je pense
pas que ça va je vais faire c'est 4 1 tu
as tué ton fils b clip p50 f2 dam des
quatre noms foulée quatre échecs à dieu
m'a dit comme ça les regarde jolie
d'ailleurs trois échecs ça échec prise
d'armes 6 3 je suis de fous ces trois
fromages e tour des quatre dames 5 crois
bouger il faut prendre mais j'ai du coup
tu veux faire trouver 4 sa tournée a été
tué juste faire tourner mais je pense
que
pas besoin de faire tout ça enfin je
peux tu veux tu peux dire je fais ça au
pire un f-16 francs du roi du monde y
aura 300 et tour de saint jacques cammas
est con mais bon enfin le journal est
très heureux j'ai envoyé deux pions
alors prenez pas pourquoi t'envoyer des
pions bon maintenant je comprends et je
vais essayer de faire x 5 ici je suis
chaud ça je peux battre et d'amour en 8
ou je sais pas david fauvel carte toi je
pars un nom je partage je pars nulle
part c'est génial c'est peut-être qu'ils
disent oui on peut être mais bon et je
comprends que on est dans les ennuis tu
prends des synthés dames 5 points alors
que tu vas faire dame s'est vite ou d'un
mot ça ne s'est pas sauvé web je te
prendre ce vin c'est fou quand cette
idée complètement ridicule mais t'en
fais pas je suis pas ta rentrée du fric
à l'apprendre l'apprendre l'apprendre là
et ça va aller ça pour les noirs tu vas
être la tour en 5 et était même mieux
pour cinq tours f5 couture pranger 5e
mm100 arrivée l'homme
bahia petite dame c5 encore mais bon ça
à faire mieux mais non je vais faire
c'est quatre de ces quatre noms qui n'a
pas un truc plus direct plus et sinon
n'importe quoi parce qu'elle normal
d'encaisser deux fois une croix f2
enfin je serai jamais sans parti hiatus
fait juste 5 ou prophylactiques
non mais c'est bizarre je pourrais te
faire au génie quand j'ai vu tous ces
trois nouvelles dates à des dames le cas
des trucs encore adam dicature un grand
maître en sueur face à l'élite quoi ces
hivers élitiste c'est comme manière de
jouer
dès qu'il prendrait cinq sapeurs ou
francis à rien
mais un échec comment en fait je vois le
truc fou logique semaine un échec nous
faire pousser 3 bon du coup on souffle
ça tue surtout demain sera pour le coup
cette dame a fui temps fut ce qui est
pénible baisse mais c'est pas content
mais je suis fou ces trois directs en
fait mon roi en place le trophée run
mais jamais roi du tour j'ai cette base
au projet hockey qui a eu lieu quatre le
job non c'est pas très bon dans quels
cas tu veux faire pression d'un prend
aussi une terme trois tours f13 le
terrain
l'échangé autour de 3 mais problème
secteur adamek 3 en outre loin ce genre
de jeu pouvoir encaisser ça c'est pas la
peine de faire cailler ou quatre mais du
coup faut trouver quelque chose qui
s'appelle l'ambiance café mvl il a fait
nul
c'est chiant pour attaquer par masque en
fait une sortie à une défense mais en
partie juste rampe et laisse paraître
sur wii wheel douloureux sacrifices
enfin conquois et tour des trois là
c'est quoi le problème est en france et
trois dames geste à mach 8 rebonds de
fer calcium
cette baisse est de finish constitution
ces quatre on veut que tout ton autre
faire roger vite faire ce que dit leur
vie après c'est qu'un troll doit faire a
laissé 4 il te dis bon coup en plus
d'eux ils bouffent pour voir le but 5 à
l'ail te fais c3 qui étaient-ils
encaisse les vidéos kf2 maintenant le
train le zinc de gens dont on peut le
dire que tour de tromper le seul coup
foot et 4,3 g 8 dames sissaoui isle adam
des quatre échecs roi de zeddam sympa il
moqué me sens hyper year a trouvé bon
alors on avait des moments où l'accord
des trois c'est déjà bien s'ils peuvent
pousser trois c'est déjà un grand truc
bon ça bon du coup elle a pas joué le
jeu et non non
des trois âges de aussi ce que ces
convois vont entreprendre là-dessus
examen du coton prend à peut-être même
pas c'était pas l'idée d'un super g 5 es
tu souffles pour sauver cette finale en
retour un peu côté adding qui dois je
pense qu'il est moins bien parce qu'en
plus il ya beaucoup de cases noires du
coup sa part en quoi se ronger 4 et
compagnie mailing ça alors j'ai du mal à
comprendre des fins il fait le beau jeu
quoi mais il joue digne mais souvent une
pléiade nuls évidemment parce qu'il est
très bien préparée et ses prépas contre
prépare mais il fait pas on dénie le
rapide en général non mais c'est beau
qu'avec les noirs il peut faire même
pente erreur fatale si ça fait longtemps
que j'avais pas vu une partie de koné
roubaix je crois qu'elle a eu un enfant
voire même deux ce qu'il en dit peu
éloigné des échiquiers le chef bah je
crois en fait mais bonne nouvelle
ben on est très heureux mais il songe
les bijoux et récemment un truc bien
revient petit à petit quoi le club de
hockey ou des sites je trouve cela s
était est l'autre grand prix non elle a
bien joué c'était le grand prix à moscou
d'enfin à skolkovo pour être précis je
peux je t'aime tu as choisi d'appeler le
grand prix moscou mist à skolkovo c'est
une petite ville à côté
on est en 2010 ouais on a en 2010 9
euros 6,6 2019 le prend place quoi qu'il
se passe ou ça toujours en place
je pense qu'on va faire un truc de
rappeurs quoi fable ebe bleed stream
2019 chaise comme wave gros tu as un
truc comme ça tu as dans les uns trop et
on ne ferait un des petits si si tu vois
un petit peu ce serait pas mal non je
sais pas vrai ce serait beau que les
trucs de rappeur si on arrivera avec nos
bling t on aurait vrai avec des groupes
bling des groupes y ont des grosses
dames tu vois en or et tout sur un truc
massif on serait la casquette tu vois
vissée sur la tête
ce serait beau non on révolutionne le
chase the game et on envoie des pièces
en un oued et du coup pour ding question
est ce que tu penses que devon voyez ni
non moi je pense que comment les mieux
mais arrivé j'ai peur que sa respiration
tiennent pas le coup non mais tu vas
avoir des gros problèmes pour devoir se
faire opérer en urgence donc je
m'attends à tout moment et tu vois il
suffoque quoi vous je n'en peux plus
quoi je suis obligé d'abandonner ben ça
a l'air si près c'est en fait son
opération que par la respiration c'est
quand même important enfin battu voire
des problèmes cardiaques tu peux avoir
des problèmes de circulation du sang de
tension enfin je me dis est-ce que c'est
approprié avec de tels problèmes de
jouer des tournois d'échecs fin et du
coup clairement dit que joue là dessus
comme si c'est un peu comme au tennis ou
avec le mec est blessé et tu vas tu fais
des petites valent pas forcément les
meilleurs mais pour le faire courir le
contre-pied son tempo quand tu es pressé
ni course de l'avant vers l'arrière
aussi c'est dur a choisi de concevoir
qu'il est difficile ouais tu souffres à
ça m'énerve ça les matches dit
oui peut plus trop courir vers l'avant
et qui te font que des amorties c'est
horrible tu profites de l'état tôt à
dire ça je pense dit ils profitent avant
et peut-être dit oui c'était une actrice
comme quand nadal appelle le médecin l'a
déjà vu sa nana qui est dominée il
appelle le médecin après il court comme
un lapin
nadal fait pas trop quand même j'ai déjà
eu à faire une fois wimbledon j'étais
vert comme la jeunesse était djokovic
murray qui grimace tout le temps mais en
fait elle est à mon fils aussi qui avait
fait ça contre bautista à goutte ya pas
très longtemps au masters de cincinnati
après chaque point ils se touchaient le
pied enfin c'est l'impression qu'il
allait abandonner mon bafa il a encore
joué un set et demi du tie break du
troisième il courir comme un lapin
j'étais très énervé après sûrement que
les mecs sur abidjan que la douleur ça
doit faire du bien c'est sûr je pense
pas qu'il fasse trop de ses fins
ça va bien je les connais pas je suis
passé d'un truc mais je pense y en a qui
le font qu'ils ont eut fait mais met
with you qu il était spécialiste la fin
des facteurs mais je sais par nadal je
pense juste qu'ils se moquent ces
douleurs oui mais non est clairement non
mais j'aime j'aime beaucoup nadal je
l'aimé pas trop tu vois dans un moment
et puis finalement je finis par les
mecquois marc harvey au début j'étais
plutôt un anti nadal qui finalement qui
vient maintenant je trouve quand même
pour céder à la base c'est pas trop
court nadal quoi mais finalement fait
beau ce qe2 symbian non mais même nadal
il a suivi il a su faire évoluer son jeu
tu vois quand tu vois le service de
nadal aujourd'hui enfin et la bosnie non
mais t'es obligé d'avoir beaucoup de
respect pour des personnes comme ça je
suis plus facile d'être anti jo courait
et je priais penny vrai mais bon j'aime
bien aussi il se bat bien mais je forme
d'un prêt c'est une histoire de mieux
caractère t touché ou pas par je sais
pas un style de jeu qu'ils dégagent
c'est d'après ya rien à dire sur le
niveau des lacs
j'ai croisé ce matin un copain en ville
et il me dit oui je vais m'entraîner
pour un club qui s'appelle la slm l'a
pas très loin de chez moi
mais d'où il s'écoule en plus parfois il
ya medvedev qui vient s'entraîner tu
pouvais très heureux quoi des fois tu
peux voir mais diesel joue un petit peu
9 on avait des infos de première main
d'allah bah oui on savait qu'ils
allaient perdre ses trois matches on est
des infos quoi mais mais en fait je sens
que j'aime pas trop son style mais le
fait qu'il habite à cannes et qui
s'entraîne à cannes ça me force à être
un peu pour lui normal bah je me sens
obligé en plus il est rouscoff un tu
vois j'ai du mal être contre mais j'aime
pas du tout son style vois trop de
points communs mick à être aurai jamais
bon mais met du coup dans mais c'est
cool si on me demande qu'est-ce que je
reviens lyon oui je serai le passage le
week end du 10 11 janvier 2020 d'où une
petite fille une tannée à villefranche
sur saône ce pas trop loin je pensais
peut-être passé la veille ou je ne sais
pas un truc comme ça tu fais quoi quand
tu vas sur lyon tu vas tu vas faire une
bonne bouffe tu gères tu passes une sur
un yacht ou quoi
je n'ai pas souvent fait dans la fois
j'avais vu pas des gens je connais des
échecs quoi mais aux oceane
mais tu te fais pas un délire bouchon
lyonnais bat faudrait que des gens qui
veulent bien le faire mais sinon oui
mais sur ce très bien c'est bien affûté
pour la nourriture
tu manges vraiment bien à lyon
franchement c'est c'est impressionnant
des berceaux de bonne bouffe annoncé
clairement un bastion après à la
fouillouse sainte et où tu manges bien
aussi à mes joueurs c'est une belle
région
non non au niveau nourriture franchement
tu te fais plaisir
ça ne se fait pas dit baucus tous les
quinze jours je suis choquée après la
ville en soit tu vois à lyon je suis pas
impressionné par la ville tu vas j'aime
bien mais je suis pas impressionné en
revanche le niveau culinaire du truc tu
vois je sens que fatiha ils ont vraiment
élever le débat niveau culinaire
non même la ville est pas si mal enfin
très fort ou pas mais déjà il ya deux le
fleuve quoi oui c'est vrai nom serait
qu'à deux clubs non mais c'est ces
jolies villas puis c'est bien c'est pas
loin de paris et aqua t1 1h40 en tgv
mettez joints de rien en fait les alpes
à côté papa et l'étoile à marseille en
même pas 2 heures ivo karlovic qui je
vous invite à lyon depuis deux mois je
suis choqué que ce soit aussi bien c'est
un peu paris sans les défauts de paris
écoutez bien vivre à cannes tonton bas
c'est un peu comme l'union mais sans les
défauts de lui en fait c'est à dire
jusque là en fait tu mets ta raison de
passer par avion parce que tu vas monter
en gamme si tu veux donc là c'est mieux
mais j'ai envie de te dire
[Musique]
c'est un peu comme lyon sauf qu'on a le
soleil et la mer donc voila en gros dans
mes factures reconnaît quand même que
cannes est un peu au dessus malgré tout
non mais ça dépend de ce que tu cherches
un ccd style de vie très différents oui
mais tu mettais d'accord que toi par
exemple si tu as va choisir entre jury
cannois agir c'est un no brainer comme
disent les anglais voir mais moi le
problème c'est que je suis pas très haut
elle côtoie donc à lyon je serai jamais
complètement à mon masque mais mais bon
ça s'apprend même personne mais mais en
fait oui mais comme cela et moi j'aime
bien et tu es une belle qualité de vie
quoique m mais après tu peux être plus
attirés par ces pas le côté plus rurale
quelque chose a plus un mot revint plus
de choses à faire
peut-être l'histoire est un peu plus ce
cas ne l'était ça bouge après la zone
est moins 50 des parts est vrai que tu
as envie de faire venir laurent elie
mais le boulot tu trouves ou bah écoute
moi je vais faire streamer je vais
gagner des milliers d'euros en faisant
streamer niveau corrigé à vitré à menton
au mois de mai kevin donc ça ira wayne
en mai mais manteau en fait le seul
avantage de menton c'est que tu es très
proche du pays des lumières quoi l
italie va donner citron allez je trompe
partout mais non mais d'italie san remo
fantastique comme il est beau redit
guerra tu as la ville des bords dit quoi
enfin c'est une très belle fille quoi
juste eu à dire la prochaine fois que tu
viens à cannes peut être on va
bordighera je connais un restaurant très
sympa aller 17 mai renom ouais mais en
fait j'ai fait vrai j'avais fait ça j'ai
mangé un peu des cèpes et des fruits de
mer est donc
non très très belle ville qu en fait
c'est pas mal ce que 26 min enfin
bordighera pardon il ya qu'une rue avoir
en fait c'est fantastique
mais elle est juste en face de la gare
c'est génial quoi tu seras la gare à
tuchan la gare tu as la seule rue bien
de la ville et tu reprends le crains tu
vas san remo raté très bien quoi bon
sens vraiment ma femme m'a obligé à y
aller voir le marché en descendant sur
barcelone plus jamais mais en fait ça
n'a aucun intérêt le marché de sang est
certes à plein de gens en fait ils sont
là ils sont pls devant le jardin le
marché de san remo c'est un truc en fait
tu l'a jamais fait ou si tu l'avais fait
le marché s'est en fait c'est juste un
marché où tu as des contrefaçons brabo
base est très [ __ ] et après ça a marché
de poisson et de légumes fin juste un
truc complètement lors landat quoi
battus chez nous quand vous marchez de
san remo c'est juste pour acheter du
poisson ou des légumes formation ça n'a
aucun intérêt
enfin mais pourquoi c'est connu bah pour
pour les sacs de contre pour les
contrefaçons en fait mais c'est des
contrefaçons écho plus ceux qui n'ont
aucun intérêt face est génial quoi
j'aurais crocodile de lacoste alors on
va faire quoi ouais c'est ça mais je
pense que dans les années 90 ce machin
les gens rient mais bien je sais pas tu
as tes genre d'endroit où ça allait
encore mais maintenant c'est fin c'est
n'importe quoi en fait les ceintures
pris ce triste envie recommencer ça
c'est un bon truc en fait à une fois
j'ai vu une contrefaçon qui a fait
mourir de rire
c'était pas dolce gabbana c'était des et
dolce & gabbana quoi c'était fantastique
mais mais du coup tu as besoin d habitat
vallauris l'an dernier autant j'ai
trouvé la région magnifique autant
cannes antibes où les autres villes
c'est vraiment pas terrible non
franchement c'est pas mal franchement ce
parce que tu connais pas bien bajaur est
ce que tu as et charles rondeau
fast-food asiatique de khanjar bout d'un
moment c'est à dire est ce que la
personne connaît les endroits les plus
saints de la ville à paris ce que tu as
déjà mangé aussi 50 à l'ifab tv cam
certains quand même pas mal d'endroits
meetic gère pas le kebab à côté de chez
moi à libanais bon bah c'est forcément c
c'est quand même assez spécial talent
kebab arménien tu as le talent face ou
d'asiatiques faf
tu as tout un tas d'endroits quoi
s'attendre après bien clairement niveau
culinaire
lyon étant su faire face à ce stream
quoi du coup le vaucluse en sueur a
complètement fermé le cadre de vie et
bien non franchement mais en fait ça
dépend si tu veux pas trop rencontrer
des gens tu veux surtout bossé faire des
trucs et tous sur internet franchement
c'est bien oui voilà face aux dépens et
puis aussi il faut comme disent nos
routes alors qu'enfin c'est un métier
que tu dois être à lyon je ne sais où
battue va pas le faire à cannes ouais
mais bon comme trimer c'est bien pour
pouvoir faire ce thriller c'est très
bien mais oui narguilé kebab de cannes
j'ai pas trop fait et tout rebond bas
voilà enfin j'ai un moment tu ne connais
pas les classiques craignent pas les
fast foods et ça c'est très compliqué
quoi c'est très très compliqué donc et
zidane a commencé à la s4 voilà enfin
enfin des références je te veux juste
une mini pause est ce que j'ai mangé
avec à la pizza critiquer la pizza la
pizzeria de mur tu as a bien sûr et
c'est ses obligés de connaître quoi bon
tout de suite vas-y du coup on a perdu
fab il était trop en sueur face à cette
discussion ait eu le conseil reste
confuse au 33 rue des suisses mais je
connais beau citron mais je connais bien
sûr enfin je connais mes classiques mais
le problème c'est que le faso
d'asiatiques et quand même au dessus
enfin au niveau culturel n'y a pas grand
chose
wen et après
non mais c'est vrai après il ya le
théâtre a honte y monte à va il ya quand
même des petits trucs quoi par ci par là
quand même un petit peu
des bons vaisseau du côté de sa mère et
moi et plus maintenant parce que ça fait
longtemps que j'ai pas le temps d'y
aller mais jus connu mais je sais pas ça
ça change les restos ça se modifie mange
pas comment on va continuer les vols on
va attendre fable on va voir un peu ce
qu'ils racontent
donc est ce que c'est un peu riches ou
comme ville écoute je sais pas je suis
choqué par l'augmentation des prix dans
les autres villes en fait
disons qu à bazas à la barre de votre
canne c'était vraiment très cher comme
ville mais maintenant comme tout est
devenu cher partout et que cannes a pas
vraiment augmenté c'est plus si cher que
ça est-ce que je peux des schémas mois à
cannes en chef chez maman je connais oui
mais ça rend team non mais je connais
quand même pas je connais pas beaucoup
de choses mais a globalement qui voit la
patte d'oie vie en france est assez cher
c'est ce que je disais il est ce que
cannes est cher en fait je trouve que
cannes est cher mais je trouve que c'est
devenu partout cher n'empêche pas ce que
tu en penses
ouais enfin je ne peux pas contre son
habitat et vivent dedans mais mais des
fois mais quand tu vas faire un petit
truc à l'étranger tu reviens tu dis mais
c'est quand même cher non mais genre tu
vois sur une telle ita des petites
exprès soit 80 centimes c'est pas mal
quoi oui madame gp10 30 en france où ça
normalement fête ses cinquante centimes
deux fois par jour enfin ça te fait vite
j'en sais rien c'est rien c'est rien à
la fin du compte 500 euros l'année quoi
juste pour boire du café quoi oui mais
bon t'as bu du café puis voilà non mais
là je parle juste du café mais imagine
pour l'instrument
j'imagine +1 je vis dedans je suis en
sueur comme toi on suit un voile a reçu
un appel à vous quoi ils se débrouillent
vous des belles parties à fond elle est
ok on peut boire d'optique a fait ça va
pour faire trimer vaut mieux pas être à
pareille on suit ça exactement barry
white world events des 8
il se redirige vers aux six f4 attention
donc en gros lot quand même des blancs
c'est le pion g4 s'il pleut en était à
angers 3 serait complètement égal voilà
c'est ça mais bon
et puis on trouve pas reculer donc on y
va fort qui couvre la case la case f4 ça
pas être évident il va faire qu'on
émette un cavalier en e2 l'un ou l'autre
je suis pas le cal peut-être g3 non mais
tu as raison je pense qu'il va arriver à
tenir mais désolé mais il va y va quand
même galéré quoi je sais pas vraiment
comment un courant tenir en fait
les radios de sky moche un qe2 qui a
valu aussi je sais pas j'ai quand même
l'impression que tu as tellement
souffrir
non mais il est pas bien enfin on fait
bon il a joué pour les journaux mais du
coup ça se retourne un peu contredit
parce qu'ils jouent un joueur moderne
qui ne joue pas pour les journaux du
coup c'est pas facile
ah non ça fait c'est pas c'est pas
évident être joueur chinois qui va
devoir dans mes cahiers des huit bien
joué mais fait quelques imprévus écoute
il va rebondir en aussi c'est
invraisemblablement me mais est ce qu'on
peut ramener lui là je sais pas
franchement là c'est un peu un peu
pénible parce qu'en plus la colonne h ça
va donner une cible au noir et à faire
car il ya eu six tours h 8 et peut-être
même des f-5 un jour suivant ce que tu
fais avec ta dam même cha suivant non
mais t'as plein de petits plans
possibles et tu peux améliorer ta aussi
poussé cette dame décide d'ailleurs
peut-être un jour si j'avais le cavalier
part pour rentrer et peut-être même tu
pousses à 5 à 4 puis si tu major en
gagnant ces quatre thèmes ou d'en bas a
juste eu fixe des trucs à droite à
gauche vincent qui a eu six jouer alors
ça reprend quand même vers le carl scène
ça reprend demain 17h domani demain 17h
cavalli est assez bien joué 1 et c'est
pour ça qu'on vous dit toujours ne pas
trop pousser les pions de votre ventre
devant 23 de base ça paraissait bofa
quand il a fait honneur à la phase 4 qui
est arrivé c'est pas beau et du coup en
fait il va se faire vissé à l'oreille
sur cette case f4 qui l'a laissée j'ai
envie de dire mais même tour 4 c'est
joli aussi kaka et j'ai trois courses
est le danger 3 et pour pas repartir en
8 mai pour venir le ca t2
et préparez cavaliers des huit qui a
réussi six as et intéressant le club
bonne partie du domaine pour l'instant
après dingli règne il calcule bien et il
est très difficile à battre à dire
exactement me défends à fond et c'est un
gros défenseur reading parrainage et une
tour atx 8 qui va arriver mais bon
est-ce que tu peux vraiment percé genre
si les blancs bouge pas on admettant
qu'on n'y arrive pas je pense pas qu'ils
aient un plan clair pour gagner enfin je
connais pas en tout cas mais augmente la
pression petit à petit à droite à gauche
c'est chiant quoi et ça peut durer très
longtemps
tu veux l'alpha 0,3 ouais pittham m
non mais t'as plein de même un truc look
et que j'ai pas envie de faire pour
l'instant mais vous avez un jour on fera
ses cahiers cinq tailles prend du coup
tu fais f prend effet qu'un retour à
suivre ex d'aidé de téthieu tour eiffe
un f4 et si tu fais j'ai 5 kg 3,45
elle c'est pas idiot mais ce qu'ils
veulent tant ben genre si cheveux qu'est
ce tu peux faire tourner autour a depuis
peu en tête 3 1 kg 5 non mais t'as avoir
jamais obtient même jusqu'où f4s que
j'allais dire mais en fait non
résolution
ouais tu peux pas mais du coup surtout
rage suite il veut quoi bein il veut
rien qui va tricoter qui alliait fin je
peux mais bon pas tout de suite mais
calais paca et les cinq cantons riches
en avoir je n'emmène ouais mais sous
rachat
kg non mais tu vas pas d'en sortir comme
ça qu'est blancois non là tu vas passer
un sale quart d'heure mais juste ce
qu'il faut pas se presser avec les noirs
non non mais c'est pour ça qu'elle a 5 à
4 tu fixes un peu les pions sur noir tu
as tu me trouves pas venir dans ces
quatre noms mais ce que m mais elle va
encore jouer contre les autres fabrice
qui va se farcir magnus pour les blitz
games pour les bolides et ci puisse
faire tira un autre ensuite si des
matchs quoi tu as deux demi finales et
donc parfois un vainqueur dans chaque
demi finale à élimination est invaincu
invaincu il est vainqueur jour entre eux
les vaincus du jour on trouve aussi un
coeur un double vaincu quoi la lecture a
tout perdu alors on nous dit un live sur
youtube horriblis oui tu vas écoute vu
que ça live sur youtube et sur twitter
en même temps tu peux éventuellement
faire le switch tu viens où tu vas et tu
viens comme tes fans en intervenant
comme vous êtes donc tu viens comme tu
es je savais j'essaye de faire des faces
même pas des blagues en fait j'ai envie
de dire c'est c'est de la merde
en fait c'est génial bah ouais mais bon
on fait possible que quand c'est parti
c'est plus le genre consacre ouais je
sais mais bon j'ai envie d'un petit peu
la suivre quand même tu vas pour voir un
peu comment ça se développe les
peut-être une victoire
le problème j'ai envie de dire c'est un
peu la cadence j'ai envie d'appeler ça
une cadence hoon est d'ailleurs ça je
vais mettre net dès qu'il ya un truc
parce qu'en fait le truc de pas mettre
les 40 coups quelque part c'est bien
j'ai envie de dire bravo parce que du
coup ça faisait une note
mais en fait la mauvaise idée c'était
peut-être de mettre 2 heures 10 si tu
veux il ya peut-être un moment il ya un
mec il est têtu à une réunion tu vas
grande chez ce soir tu as les mecs
étaient l'afutt avais tu avais tous les
fleurons du grand duché ce tour qui
était assis t'avais les pontes du grand
duché ce tour elle atteint mec qui lâche
un truc que peut-être on va permettre de
rajouter au 40e et au moins ce sera plus
tu as plus chaud mais déjà ce mec là en
fait son idée c'était de faire 1h30 plus
30 secondes chaos
tu as su lire et là tu as un autre mec
en fait que dix excellente idée tu
allais bravo tu as tu as déjà fait
peut-être une petite tape sur la tête
gestionnaire
bravo tu vas me [ __ ] de sa gueule et à
dire la lettre du 2h10 direct du coup
ferme-la et du coup cet autre mec en
fait il n'a pas à tuer il n'a pas pu
poser ses couilles sur la réunion et du
coup on est avec cette cadence je pense
ça c'est un peu passé comme ça dans sa
série que disons que s'il avait 48 2
mois au début dingila plus de 13 minutes
tu as donc tu peux te dire tu as des
joueurs
ben non ils se sont dit on va encore
allongé le truc
à c mais tout ça c'est parti d'un mec je
pense dans la réunion qui avait une
bonne idée de base mais c'est court
circuiter nous ont gâché son idée sais
pas s'il ya des gens qui ont déjà fait
qu'ils ont déjà travaillé dans des
boîtes des grosses boîtes yade est
longue des grosses réunions mais je sais
pas si vous avez remarqué les mecs ou
s'il ya que moi qui ai remarqué ça quand
il ya une grosse réunion dans une
société avec beaucoup de monde si vous
êtes dans un truc qui marche pas très
bien où est un peu pourri il ya souvent
un gros problème c'est que si tu as une
idée où il ya quelqu'un qui a une idée
intelligente mais qu'à un poste assez
bas tu as forcément un mec qui a un
poste plus haut qui va qui va dire bonne
idée mais qui va vouloir histoire de
thua de paternité l'idée qui va rajouter
un truc que ce soit bien ou mal
qu'est ce que je veux dire bon an mal
mais c'est souvent mal parce que du coup
ouais ben c'est pas tout le temps mal
mais c'est souvent malouet du goûter un
mec qui lâche une bonne idée puis en
fait il aurait mieux fait de rien dire
parce que ça va être récupérée par les
autres qui vont vouloir se paternité
l'idée qu'ils vont rajouter d'autres
trucs et ça va ça va mal ça va bien se
passer quoi tu vois et bah du coup j'ai
basculé déjà remarqué ça dans votre
expérience
mais moi j'ai déjà travaillé dans une
boîte où les réunions se passer comme ça
ça n'avait pas de rapport avec les
échecs le truc où je bossais du coup
mais ça se passe c'est toujours comme ça
et toujours des gens qui lâche et des
bonnes idées genre moi par exemple pour
prendre un exemple une personne qui a
des idées intéressantes et à un moment
donné j'ai la meilleure idée c'est de
rien dire parce qu'en fait si tu veux
lâche un truc en fait les gens m'ont de
modifier sa devenir un truc pourri et
pour le bien du truc en fait vaut mieux
rien dire tu as une idée non pas trop là
en fait monter à 40 mille idées mais tu
sais que de toute façon elle est empirée
quoi donc
mais je reste a déjà assisté à ce genre
de réunions interminables voit pas trop
mais en fait je suis un peu contre les
réunions ça marche trop hâtif et réunir
avec toi même sinon oui ça damas qui
compte ça va mais tu vois de st je peux
me tromper mais que c'est un truc un peu
brasser du vent mais montrer qu'on fait
quelque chose ça leur chante train de
faire quelque chose regardez on fait de
réunion on est là on est tous là on
travaille mais fait tu fais rien enfin
l'impôt salle dédiée à donc le hiatus
sens que mes nerfs et je pense de base
c'est une bonne idée en fait
mais lucas qui a couru [ __ ] il avait
voulu mettre son petit grain de sel et
il a transformé ces réunions ça ouais
c'est ça en fait n'a du coup je préfère
les brainstormings brainstorming tu at&t
dans un genre d'open office était un peu
tout le monde qui balancent des idées il
ya des gens qui note puis après bon t'as
un genre de boîte à idées tu vois je
préfère les brainstormings aux réunions
au nord jusqu'à la boîte et des métaux
courants
oui mais là on touche pas tu parles
machin boîte mais je sais pas s'il ya
des gens dans le chat qui ont déjà voilà
qui ont déjà avec déjà fait ce genre de
réunion c'est que moi qui avais pas de
bol et qu'ils aient jamais de bonnes
raisons rouge travail non mais je pense
est une constante partout tout le temps
c'est elle qui dit tu savoures ton café
en écoutant pas du tout celui qui parle
est you show late adresse à peu ce que
je faisais après mais tu ressors les
sidéens de ce genre de réunion c'est
fait et très fatigant fait moi j'en
pouvais plus rien à rien comme ça je
peux plus travailler la journée quoi ça
m'avait fatigué tu es obligé de prendre
sur toi pendant tout le truc c'est très
chiant thuvien je vois je trouve c'est
très fatigant mentalement en fait les
frais de la championne qui a le même
genre de réunions tu vois si je fais des
réunions start up on parlait du génie de
steve jobs soit entretenue toi et fais
assez marrant quoi bon du coup fabien
entourage suite tourache un bon ami mais
à ce que tu pensais et là on ne savait
pas je découpe à sahin que je sais pas
quoi je voulais faire à 5 à 4
une histoire de goût 4 il te rigolent
ils fêteront un jour
bon un jour pas trop vite le temps ils
doivent bien surveillé 24 bien comme il
faut
j'arrive terre qui demande news bon
maxime a fait nul oui mais cette partie
là et cloud sont en cours on sait pas si
tu te situes ce péché c'est que tu avais
rien à y faire nommer ce que je lui
expliquais c'est quand tu sais que si tu
m'aimes suis lâche une idée elle va être
tellement re manipuler tout ça que c'est
ça tu vas te retrouver avec des parties
sans rajoutant au cas où vous que c'est
une bonne idée mais mais qui dure qui
dure six heures alors vas tu vas te
retrouves avec ce qu'on est en train de
voir clairement donc donc donc non
m'écoute pas bon avoir pour le moment
est la partie se déroule on va voir
comment comment les vannes fait là il a
joué tous les coups logique et
maintenant il va falloir qu'ils qui
pressent pour arriver on va de communes
a pas de risque et qu'il habite une
bonne position on va voir frais pour
l'instant la tourache un jeu très bien
passé ça te défends h35 ouvrage 2 donc
ya pas les genres tous les vitamines des
trucs comme ça donc sûrement que les
vannes va devoir un moment passé en
force à un petit f 5 un truc racheter du
poids mais du coup il peut quand même
essayer de l'améliorer avant
tranquillement hollande si les leçons
sur chelsea devrait pas être en français
bat écoutes elles ont toutes été
traduite et on attend que les gens
l'implémenter dans le site
donc ça peut arriver demain ça peut
arriver d'une minute à l'autre en fait
tapotant arriver aujourd'hui comme dans
une semaine mais le problème c'est que
la semaine dernière il y avait cinq
giving aux états unis quoi du coup les
mecs ont fait le pont coiffe un genre
peu plus lent fait précédemment pas de
chance 5 giving non mais au moins vingt
ils bossent à noël
nabil bref tout le temps en fait tu
gères que cinq bris choix que c'est le
seul moment de l'année où ils font un
pont quoi ils ont quatre jours de break
ouais en fait c'est en réponse à ça
qu'on l'a pas encore chez nous c'est en
fait on se prend tous leurs trucs tout
le temps
jarre halloween fonds sais pas pourquoi
on le bailliage on l'a vraiment que
c'est devenu un truc un alouette c'est
insupportable fini donc choses divines
pour en quatre jours aux foins ball boxe
est un truc bien donner loc
alors il ya un truc affreux assez à
halloween c'est ne surtout pas appelé
mon père parce que tu dis à l'oit jeudi
win quoi j'en peux plus quoi chaque
année il a fait le travail de nuit c'est
halloween comme levier très heureux de
sa blague il a fait depuis dix ans enfin
tu suis à fond quoi je l'appelle plus
quoi ces jours là enfin elle aussi non
bastien le tiralo à l'huile aussi faim
tu as et il peut être très très choquant
mais bon le truc de halo qui te réponds
wincc face est très mal et ça en fait du
coin battue
j'écoute oui il faut être là il attend
quoi c'est un vrai tueur devant cette
blague que j'attends d'eux
faudrait vraiment qu'on prenne mon père
sur un stream mais il m'en a raconté une
bonne si elle m'a raconté une bonne
blague
la semaine dernière voilà l'histoire
d'une souris qui vit dans un bar et il
ya un gros chat qui vit dans le bar
aussi et du coulage couvrir le chat y
roder tout du coup la souris aller
planquer et elle attend que le chat
partent pour pour sortir essayer de
choper du fromage ou abou fait quoi et à
un moment donné la souris en temps à
voyez donc et c'est bon ça va il ya le
chien donc le chat à ces parties la peur
du coup selon vous ouverte la souris
sort le chat la chope et lui dit tu vois
que ça sert d'être bilingue sais pas si
jeune j'ai très heureux de cette
magouille bravo enfin une banderole
enfin c'est joli ça je serais déçu
d'être bilingue pour une fois qu'ils me
kim qui me raconte une blague qui me je
me dis pas c'est pas possible
pourtant j'ai jamais entendue à
charbonnières
emilie bilingue très heureux il m'a
raconté une autre mais a été tellement
ridicule que je me rappelle plus mais ça
sentait jamais très évolués quoi si mon
père était sur internet clairement il
suivrait le twitter de bigard coiffe est
évident c'est des failles sur haddad
mais sinon oui il sait pas ce qu'ils
ratent quoi c 'est toujours dans ce
registre quoi du coup très dangereux de
laisser mon père et vlad on semble enfin
là c'est le festival quoi ils
rebondissent d'un sur l'autre sur le
truc
oui oui tu t'en sors plus là bon les
banales est revenu un coup quoi
n'accélère moi cette cadence très
peut-être mon père vienne en fait on a
les stream deux parties longues nettes
et des moments comme ça hop on lui passe
le micro est ce que mon papa regarde les
vidéos alors y'a un truc très drôle avec
mon père en fait c'est que normalement
il me dit pas les vidéos qu'ils
regardent en fait il suffit que je sois
pas là où qui voit quelqu'un que je
connais c'est pour qu'ils lisent mes
vidéos sont géniales mais s'il me voit
c'est de la merde non une bosse et de la
mer tu regardes pas forcément c'est
incroyable had a alors là c'est très
bien la wla della donc toi tu pars le
moins malades par le flux du coup cette
chaîne prend qualité tient à ça on a
tous remarqué m est ce que c'est
vraiment qualitatif c'est ce que c'est
pas du divertissement que je maintenant
donc
c'est chez nathan je te suis peut-être
dire jeunes athlètes on se refait la
partie en mode vlad quoi des quatre où
j'ai pu bien sûr prévu ce coup quoi
c'était sûr qu'elle jouerait sa contre
les bonnes il y avait eu un doute
évident auquel m6 pareil fou b4 bien
évidemment il joue l'animent zoo moi je
ne sais pas 3 rock mais je pas qu'est ce
qu'il pourrait dire comme conneries wlan
non en fait il aura avancé et où il aura
avancé vite et puis ils auraient regardé
j'ai quatre noms mais comment fais tu
pour jouer sur coup ce que tu es ce que
tu es 2800 ou est ce que tu es
il y en eut ce deuxième race ryad quoi
ces genres est ce que tu es 1800 pour un
tel coup quand tu affaiblis ton droit
complètement relâché ça va pas marcher
quoi mais pourquoi pas ça aurait pu quoi
vraiment longue bah ouais non mais
attention tu rachètes road rash 4 kf3
gratuite atteint le petit frisson
l'allant noms évoqués ci fais ça je peux
pas dire non mais il peut pas faire non
by the way the tourist giratoire le
rattrape bas peut-être non m'évoquer si
c'est juste fou parmi les mieux dernier
pourra toujours faire nul dans deux
heures si l'on vit
[Musique]
non mais s'il fallait faire autant mais
je serais surpris quoi j'aime dire tu
serais déçu non surpris non mais c'est
impossible qu'il fasse parce que là rien
ne me déçoit en fait normal mais
vraiment fait partie de ce tournoi donc
non mes cavaliers froid à tous gratuite
qui a aidé 2c répète non un maison de
rendre à boston
non mais c'est à lui sinon peu vrai
bavois la tourache un rose bonbon ce nom
mais c'est juste incroyable
je comprends votre nom mais ok peut-être
qu'il a très bien a jugé que l'on
pouvait pas gagner deux positions je ne
sais pas quoi mais quand même tu essayes
un peu une faune bp tue fait de trop de
menaces les blancs défendent bien et
fait nul dans vingt coups maintenant la
bombe la c-zéro tipi non mais c'est
étonnant là quand même
leading qui réfléchit que oui ce que je
fais est nul mais attends ça fait
vraiment 3 on est d'accord un tour à
tour à je suis tout rachat il ya une
fois non mais c'est sûr si tu as eu trop
de l'allier deux flops gestion et là il
va ya trois foires et ouais ça fait
trois fois ça fait une fois deux fois
trois fois oui oui c'est fait qu'il y
ait des deux c'est nul mais c'est sûr
que là ils appellent l'arbitraire caïds
et deux nuls les arbitres sont même nom
vous pouvez pas faire mieux non mais je
sais pas ça ne peut étonner mais surtout
que je trouve qu'il est mieux juste au
moment où je commence à ce qui fait que
la position des noirs et meilleures
balles à casey fca est ce qu'on fait ce
carré l'équipe arrive en f4 bataoui
casey de quatre tas le fou qui bien
quand même
la seconde porte et qui est des cases
noires affaibli et voilà et c'est avec
les noirs tu décides site ouvre à kiev 5
à un moment où ce que tu veux faire
donc tu as plein de
qui disait tu peux essayer de tourner
mal tu accumules des slips s dans le
chat un peu salée c'est signé bah on a
bien fait de rester finalement fab tuant
neuf et vingt minutes de plus bon bah on
a vu la pleutrerie du truc quoi pleutre
pleutre et bah voila quoi dire bon bah
tout se décidera dans les rapides et
liszt quoi enfin c'était très utile
d'organiser deux premières journées
ouais ouais ce level de slip est c'est
que alfred watch la web écouter
petite déception quand même affable
d'avoir vu deux parties comme ça assez
il note enfin vraiment très
inintéressante là pour la peine non mais
ok commandeur celle de maxime ne peut
pas reprocher grand chose
il a été surprise par l'ouverture que
magnus à jouer et bon ben ok après tu
dois réagir en live et il n'a pas pris
de risque c'est bien normal et on de
coquettes nul très compréhensible voilà
enfin un ami ça et là à rognan pour le
coup là je sais pas ce qui fait un
talent énorme a une chance de peut être
gagnée il m'a dit ça y est j'ai
quasiment envie de m'excuser pour ce
stream dans le sens où bah désolé les
mecs vous allez regarder vraiment des
parties pourries mais on n'y pouvait
rien quoi c'était way la partie de petro
a financé le meilleur le moins du truc
moi je leur montre ce que on a adoré de
la r&d de vanina ça va quand on a vu des
trucs intéressants vraiment la partie de
pétrole ont fini sur petrov
bonjour il faut faire graver en corse
interdire le nul par accor
voilà je pensais pas s'appeler troisième
position nous questionnent si les mecs
jouent ça pendant 1000 coups de suite
ils vont refaire en au retour à schwyz
tour h4 non mais ça y est j'ai quasiment
envie de m'excuser ce qui s'est passé
c'est 30 la merde ça fera moins de se
faire rembourser le journal devant le
valentine aurait on va te dire une seule
partie ou peu de parties lentes ce ça
peut très bien arriver truc ouais enfin
là c'était aujourd'hui c'était une
nouvelle fois assez sévères
non mais je dis ah ok pendant sting que
field au moins il ya les six parties tu
vois oui est bon maintenant l'autre
allait toujours avoir un truc
intéressant tu avais un nombre qui est
toujours mieux ou des trucs mais tu as
toujours des partis comme ça aussi dans
le lot et que tant des deux en fait ça
peut très bien arriver
oui enfin là ça fait 4 we fall a
aujourd'hui 7 2 hier j'ai pas un maxime
cet intéressant pour moi il ya eu un
petit moment il peut y avoir nullement
interdit
non mais c'est quoi ce parti posté une
partie de petrov contre journaux qui
s'est jouée dans des journaux font sais
pas en fait mais bon du coup c'est pour
montrer quelque chose de beau qui s'unit
par là nul voilà mais par une goutte
choix me paraît que la partie de
maksimir snippers nul à s'animer c'est
intéressant
ouais il ya des idées non mais les coûts
de fab on a pas eu de bol au tirage est
ce qu'on aura de la chance au grattage
sûrement donc demain on se retrouve à 17
heures pour aller rapide il y aura il y
aura du décide ce sera marrant demain
pour la peine au mans puis tu seras avec
vlad ca d'apple china font quoi oui bah
bras après tu est tributaire des partis
aussi je vais te dire si hier on a eu
avec vlad battue on ne peut pas y faire
grand chose c'est difficile de commenter
non recevoir aux journaux comme passer
un bon moment
oui oui mais tu vas enfin juste et mieux
si les parties étaient animés etc
enfin moi j'ai pas besoin de mots - non
plus mais tu as chante toujours une
petite culpabilité par rapport au public
on a envie de parler d'échec qui ont
fait on a envie de voir des belles
parties mais quand c'est comme ça c'est
difficile quoi c'est un peu je suis
toujours un petit peu triste femmes
noires du parti comme ça ça me chiffonne
tu vois non franchement 2,00 euros de
tipi pour ce journal nul que les mecs à
demain et bat fab
belle façon ce fait la vidéo de résumer
eiffage hershey falloir aller c'est le
passage obligé ça va être dur mais c'est
comme ça on va souffrir hadmar l'élite